Fuck is going on.
Everybody.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by audible.com
audible.com who has been one of the
longest running podcast sponsors is uh,
the best resource for
audio entertainment online.
It's a fantastic website and they have
over a hundred thousand different titles
and it's audio books, it's podcasts, it's,
they have comedy,
it's just hundreds of thousands of
different titles and it's all just
entertainment that you can listen to while
you're in traffic while you're on the
subway,
while you're on a plane all the times.
That would generally just be a big fat,
stupid waste of time.
You can actually enjoy the shit out of
him with audible.com and if you go to
audible.com forward slash Joe,
you can get one free audio book and
30 free days of audible service.
As you can see, there are
pals, opie and Anthony,
they have their episodes available on
audible.com they've got old lectures,
they've got like really interesting,
cool shit, comedy specials, you know,
a audible also has that whisper sync
application that I've talked about before.
But quite honestly, I've never
used it. I just heard it's awesome.
I have a regular one I can't have,
I'm too fucking add.
When I put my shit on an audio, like if,
uh, if I, uh, if I'm actually reading,
I have to have it on something
that I can only read a book on.
And those kindle fire,
HDX, those are pretty dope.
They do a lot of different shit
that you can watch movies on them,
you can get online with them.
It's like an iPad essentially.
And I cannot be having one of those.
I'm just, I just fucking, I'll just,
I'll screw off.
So I've never tried it.
But if you are a person who
has more control than I do,
the kindle fire HD has a
thing called whisper sync.
And what it is is you read the book at
night or whenever you want to and then
when you get in your car,
it will literally pick up the audio
book right where you left off the book.
It's incredible.
Like it,
it knows where you're reading ends and
that's where the actor will pick up and
reading the book.
It's really fucking cool.
audible.com forward slash Joe and
get yourself a free audio book.
We're also brought to you by on
[inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t if you have never heard of on it
on it is essentially what I would call
a human optimization website.
We sell you cool shit that's good for you.
Cool Shit like kettle
bells and battle ropes and,
and even ones that are artistic.
We have kettle bells like the primal
bells that are designed in the form of
different apes and the new Zombie
bells that y'all self explanatory.
They're all zombies.
Uh,
the idea being that we
are all children and uh,
we have never grown up and it's not
happening now. Bitches too late.
Missed the boat, missed the boat
on growing up. I liked zombies.
I don't give a fuck if
I'm almost 50. I care. No,
I like what I like enlarge handles
for grip and these kettlebells,
they're also balanced 3d balance.
We had it,
we made sure that there were functional,
not just cool looking,
but they are definitely that
we sell basically functional
strength equipment and
a lot of really cool supplements.
The supplements all, um,
they're all the very best as far as
ingredients, as far as the dosages,
as far as the purity of the
best stuff that we can find.
And we tried to sell it to you as
ethically as possible. In fact,
when you buy supplements from on it
and like Alpha brain or shroom tech,
there is a 30 pill,
90 day money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product.
It just, it just say this stuff sucks.
You get your money back.
We are banking on the fact that a,
it's the best stuff that does work and
there's science behind it and all of its
explained that on at.com if you
go peering around, but that we,
we want you to give you stuff that
you're actually going to enjoy,
so you're going to want to buy it again.
No one wants bad relationships with
people that feel like they got ripped off.
So we're trying,
we're trying to eradicate that as much
as possible by just selling you the best
shit we can find and if we don't think
it's good, we don't sell it. If we,
and if we try it and like, you know what,
this isn't working for me or is this,
this isn't getting good feedback
from people, we would get rid of it.
We would never put anything up there
that we haven't already been using
ourselves.
That's the whole idea behind it.
Room checks for sport has changed my
life and the gym. It's fantastic stuff.
Tremendous. And I was
scared at first. I was like,
am I getting a fucking audit tac?
And then I found that it just pumped
blood red blood cells and t it just helps
the blood optimization.
Fucking great oxygen.
I'm 300 pounds and I bounce and I
go to kickboxing so it works well.
It gives you a little extra pump is what
us a little extra pick me up. It's a,
it's got cordyceps mushroom and vitamin B,
12 in it and a quarter step.
Some mushroom is a mushroom
that the Chinese Olympic
team first started using to,
uh,
kick people's asses.
They found the supplement that a mushroom
that gives you more endurance and it's
noticeable. It's a real feeling.
And I also think it's very legal.
There's vitamin B 12 in it as well.
Um, you can see there the ingredients.
If you're watching this episode,
which most people don't,
there's a lot of antioxidants as well,
and two different types of cordyceps
mushrooms. And that is the, uh,
the magic mushroom that is, uh,
very bioavailable. We find the, the,
the best form of it. We actually
get it from caterpillars. They,
they grow it on Caterpillar somehow
or another. I don't understand it.
That's cool. It's beyond my stupid
brain. But it's good for you on a.com.
O.
N N I t use the code name,
Rogan save 10% off any
and all supplements jihad.
My Friends Joey Diaz
is here praise owed and
the Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Good googly Mooglie. Joey Diaz. What's
up? Beautiful. Good googly Moodley.
We, uh, we did find the origin of
great googly Mooglie w what was it?
It was like from 19, it was
the great, it was great.
Googly [inaudible] was the first
one and it was from like the 1970s.
Do you remember where you heard it?
I heard it from a kid from North Carolina.
Where's all the marine station in North
Carolina? Uh, love of based. That was,
that's what he was from.
He grew up there like he was a,
and he used to always know that I bring
up a big rocket Cokie go good googly
Mowgli. He was with, with a North
Carolina accents. Zappa, isn't it? Yes,
it's from Frank Zappa. It's great. Googly
Mooglie. It's from the Frank Zappa song.
Nannuki rubs it.
1974 74.
Huh?
Have you ever put Frank Zappa?
With that fucking band like Frank's
garage and that's really good man.
They were weird. Fucking crazy.
Like after a while you're like,
I can't do this no more.
But one of the best drummers that we
have today originated from that band.
He created missing persons,
him and his wife daily.
Terry Bozzio who was in
playboy. Wow. Who gives a fuck.
I found out about Frank
Zappa from my friend Tom.
I was probably like 10 or 11 years
old and uh, I had this one friend,
he's a weird kid and his dad was weird
as fuck. His Dad was a super hippie man.
He drove a sob.
I'll never forget that his dad had this
like really weird car where the fucking
key was on the floor.
You ever see a sob police cars in Aspen,
Colorado? Are they really?
That's what they drive. And
Aspen south. It makes sense.
I bet. I bet those things drive
really fuck goodness. No, they're,
they're made by an aviation company. Like
was initially an ADHD still out there.
I think
they have a weird body style.
They're very weird. But you know
by the a insignia, Saab has a very,
can you pull it up Brian?
There's someone who's trying
not to look flashy on purpose.
It's like a car that you can get when you
know it's a really well engineered car
but it's,
that's a non flashy car.
Like a Saab is like an under the radar
sorta like really nice high end car stops
actually closed down. There were
one of the dealers done. Oh No,
they went under when uh,
nobody was buying them it Tufts sell well,
they have that reputation of being ugly,
fucking ugly.
They're these ugly understating
really well engineered by Cadillac.
He wanted to like recently
the worst way way.
When you're Cuban, that's
success. Why don't you buy it?
Because when I mentioned
it on the podcast,
fucking service writers that work at
Cadillac places where secretly emailing me
going don't, oh no. It to paint this bad.
No problem with this. I mean so many.
This, how long ago was this really mean?
Should go, yeah, the
CTSV just one car. The,
I don't know but took a cow like
people hit me up going to dog.
Just move on because maybe the, I live
in service, maybe you know that now.
That's the heavy duty one, which I didn't
care cause I would lease them. She,
I like leasing cars cause you get much
more of a car for your money if you don't
have money. That's what you do. Your
lease up fucking car. Especially.
The reality is cars are good
for a few years. Then we
get rid of him before anything goes wrong.
I wish got so I was leaning towards the
Cadillac. I drove it. I fucking love that.
Just can't get it that minute.
You want to cry like you pick a scar face.
Then when they showed up with
the Cadillac, what did he
say to her? Cadillac? Yeah,
the Cuban. No Real Cuban
man. When I saw that I go,
they had a really good consultant.
Listen, you need a Cadillac in your life.
You understand what he's telling me?
This makes me think you need to get,
I was so sad when the service
writers talked me out of it.
I want to buy American.
Fuck those.
I want to do all this shit and
then I went on the Subaru thing.
I've had three supers. I go,
it's time to get something else,
but Subaru sold me with the fucking
free service, I think. Got You.
Were free service. Customer
satisfaction. That's customers.
I always say in the next couple of years,
everybody's going to have a good product.
It's going to be so competitive,
so how people are going to beat
you out is by customer service.
You know you go to a four seasons hotel
in Denver and the one in Chicago is two
big differences.
Then you go to that Harley Davidson hotel
that you took me to them. No walkie.
That's one of the best hotels around.
You can't stay still in that hotel
without somebody coming up to you going,
can I get your water? Can I get your
menu? You need a ride and you're like,
what the fuck? It's all cut salt.
When I found out that about Subaru,
that's what made me go back to the
Subaru. I see. Because it's free.
It's free service now.
I still got to pay for brakes and tires,
but all I got to do is bring it in for
the 1500 we're going to for 3,500 right.
I see what you're saying, man. I don't
know Joey. I still really please.
I was getting goddamn kind of a white
one. No, you haven't gotten it yet? No,
I got the Subaru, the new Subaru
last week. You did. So you're done.
I want them done it. Uh, okay. So we, we,
there's no sense in talking about this.
Good luck with the Subaru. Oh, I love it.
You don't meet them. At least it's up.
Dude.
If you decided to go second car Super Bar,
If you do that one day, which I can
see in the Joey Diaz future for sure.
Second car Superbowl, you're getting to
Goddamn Cadillac. Okay. Got It. Got It.
Sits is passion. If you enjoy it. Look,
I had a Mustang gt 500 and
it was a piece of shit.
I'm going to be honest with you. It's like
a new one. Yeah. This is a problem. Yeah,
it's, it's got, I had a 2010 and um,
there was a lot of issues with the car.
Like as far as like the way it would
drive, it's because of the rear axle.
They've got a what's
called a library or axle.
It's like a big fat log on the end that
connects to two tires. It's just not the,
uh, the, the optimum setup. And
like when you drive it around in it,
there's a lot of body flax cause it was
a convertible better than the previous
years, but still you could, it felt like
uneasy when you're driving it. That said,
I had more fun in that car.
Then I think any car I've had,
like I've ever owned ever,
because it was so stupid because it was
so loud and it was so fun and I was like,
Holy Shit, I'm driving around in a
fucking Mustang. You know, it was fun.
It was like there's something to that,
like maybe the bill quality's not as nice,
but what's the philosophy?
The car and we'll the,
the Shelby,
the philosophy was,
let's take something that
doesn't make any fucking sense.
Let's take way more power than anybody
needs. Slapping it in his fucking car,
put a crazy exhaust on it, make it
such as it burns rubber and every gear,
anytime you want. It's a retarded car.
And when you have something like that,
it's you know,
it's all for fun when you're driving.
If you're trying to fucking
Cadillac CTSV these goddamn things.
Beat Ferrari's and drag
races, horsepower, ridiculous.
It's in the 500 Oh, it's ridiculous.
I'll tell. I'll tell you exactly.
It's a ridiculously fast car.
They're,
they're one of the most powerful
a sedans that you can buy today.
Do they go zero to 60
I drove and I drove the one under that.
I'm not going to lie that and
drive the CV XD with all of them.
Jesus Christ, less than four seconds.
They go zero to 60 in 3.9 seconds.
556 horsepower. That's insane. How bad.
There's life in the service department.
Seriously.
How bad is it?
How bad is on when they can't fix your
fucking car and you only had one car and
I were just going through it.
I'm looking at,
yeah. Yeah. The good thing
is is that that some dealers,
depending on how old or new your cars,
they'll just give you a rental car.
Like they gave me this loaner car,
which is fine, that Volkswagen,
when you drive driving a
fucking fat silver cts V and
you just enjoying the shit
out of it so it breaks every
now and again. You bring it in,
they fix it up. When you're driving
it, you're going to enjoy it.
This is going to be a feeling that you
don't get when you were in that fucking
Subaru. The Subaru was reliable.
It'll get you where you want to go,
but it pours the piss out of you. It's
a different experience. This is Iceland.
It's nice,
but it's not like this crazy thing.
I grew up in Jersey and I grew up in
the metropolitan area and as you know,
you just grew up around people.
I went to boulder,
I went to Colorado and then really
went to Bolton when I lived in boulder.
I enjoy living there because
I always felt stupid.
I felt him securely because he's hasn't
got a big universal mark people there.
A lot of smart people there and I'll
tell you all those smart people,
I couldn't argue them out of the
Subaru. They would come like, Oh,
if I gave you this car, the voice, you
know, and I'd say, what about Toyota?
And they would say, look, a guy
in boulder, this Subaru people,
and it was Toyota people.
That's Toyota.
People that have one of those jeeps
that they don't even make. No.
What do they, what do they call?
They paid top dollar like people,
if you sell one with 300,000 miles,
some genius white dude will come to
your house and there's snow. Good.
I'm going to call looking at it and make
you a cash offer or pay you a thousand
over book. And then you're like, what
plan do you have with this? I'm sorry man,
I'm going rip this engine. Engina and
you're like, what do you do for a living?
I'm an electronic engineer. I run
via electronic, whatever runners.
That's what they are.
No, no. The other one,
the one before I even make them no
more than those little ones. Yeah,
the old nothing.
Let them clinics out of anchorage because
the Land Cruiser is a land rover over
right.
Rover and Land Rover
you, it is a land cruiser. It doesn't
Land Cruiser. His Land Rover. Right.
But the Land Rover, Land Rover, I got
confused belongs to Toyota and embolden,
you can't buy a new land cruiser.
People won't buy the new ones because
the power going to bleed hill.
So people are going for the old ones and
then like putting super engines in them
instead you fucking took them to,
you know they have a specialty like even
bolder had Birch Subaru is the biggest
dealer in the world.
Then number like eight is Subaru.
But they had so many
Subarus and bold with it.
You couldn't take it to the
service department or at Denver.
So what happened was this guy left the
Subaru Organization and opened it by Lee
Hill. Super Repair. That was
navy. All they did with Subarus.
And I used to talk to that guy
and he would talk my ear off,
but that dude knew about cars and
he sold me. Like he was like, look,
if I had $1 million, I still have
a Subaru. My parking lot wise,
I know I could depend.
He would talk to me about it like he had
been a Subaru since 1968 there's a lot
of who that is really dedicated
to those old Toyota said,
oh in Colorado because
they know what it is.
You know what it was when you went down
that hill that night with your wife.
You know what it's like.
What does those Subarus have like the
most sophisticated four wheel drive system
for those kinds of cars.
Like when you look at like the top
10 cars to driving in the snow,
at least two at a 10 where Subarus
when they had this most reason,
top 10 lists, they have good ground
clearance. You know, they just,
they just figured out
how to make a car that,
I mean the success is so
undeniable in Colorado.
You look around and you see Subarus.
Colorado is number one. I think Montana,
Wyoming, they just, people learn. They
make a living. Just on those three states,
Subaru makes a fortune just on three real
American states that people who moved
to New Mexico have them. The Mexico is
very sophisticated by where they ski,
not where they shot the longest
yard or Albuquerque. No, up more.
It's fucking gorgeous.
Like Santa Fe is that when a Santa Fe
is gorgeous but up more? Just one town.
Las Cruces. Las Cruces. Yeah. I
don't know that town very well.
You were in the mountains. It's
no big. It's really beautiful.
It's a green chili on everything.
We should do a Gig in New Mexico.
I've never done anything in your mouth.
It's just so tough.
They closed the comedy club down.
I spoke to clay Weda.
Clay has a friend that has
a rock club in New Mexico.
We contacted them two or three times a
guys like not sold on it. He doesn't know.
Come on, let's do it. You and me show
there. Well, let's go do it. Let's do it.
We'll get the agents to
do it. Yeah, let's do it.
So I have to switch around to find a
place. Yeah. Whatever's the best pot.
Santa fe or Albuquerque has more people.
Yeah.
Albuquerque and we grind the
experts. I can trust me. And then I,
I've done research on New Mexico,
said Tate's from there instead of that.
You don't really want to go outside of
Albuquerque. I heard. Really? No, no.
Santa Fe.
Santa Fe is cream of the crop.
Albuquerque is bad boys,
bad boys,
bad boys crack. He is the
real deal though. Yeah,
there's a lot of that.
Diego Sanchez ain't fucking around.
He's down there and running shit. They
fucking drove down now. They really do.
They really throw down
down there. So, but uh,
it can be interesting just to go
down and do a fucking Nice, yeah,
I've never been,
I need to go.
There's a lot of this parts of this
country that I've never been like you ever
been to the Dakotas, north or South? Yes.
Did you go and see the Mount Rushmore?
Yes.
Really?
I did comedy and not
Snake River to the south,
which they used to have a weekend gig
there and I was Jonesing for blow and I
couldn't find any.
And I looked into the kitchen and there's
one Mexican in the fucking kitchen and
he popped out and that was the end
of that phone. Wow. That is so crazy.
Tribble used to have rooms. Uh,
him and his partner had rooms.
When I first started in north and South
Dakota and South Dakota was a little
dirty or I could be dirty.
It was a Friday, Saturday.
So I would drive from Colorado to snake
river, green river, something river.
You know what I did all through Idaho?
I did go one in Idaho would evil Knievel
jumped that rib snake river river.
You do twin falls, snake river, Boise,
American American or whatever
with an eight air force bases.
You do all that shit on those j Co the
potato run one and potato run to wow.
And you'd do everything American. What
the fuck is the Air Force Base in Idaho?
American home,
American something fucking you do
everything up there at twin falls.
I fingered a fucking Indian chick.
I told you the other day,
Yoga came out of the fucking
monkey at twin falls.
Fucking amazing. And she was a
real Indian, not like a, you know,
like not from India.
Isn't that hilarious?
You're saying a real Indian mean native
American. Not like a person from India,
which is actually an Indian.
She took,
you got to confuse me for one. I'm
confused too man. We're both confused.
Yeah. This one is a bunch of spots
and I've never been to man. Uh,
I don't think I've ever been in Wyoming.
Great Place. Yeah, it looks cool. Very,
very frigid.
It looks very cowboy to very
cowboyish feelings like state cowboy.
They keep rocking it.
You have Cheyenne.
I'm going to tell you something and
you're not going to believe this.
And you know me.
Cheyenne,
Wyoming at some of the best Chinese
food I have rated my fucking life in the
states. Well, I believe you, man.
I used to drive from boulder on
Fridays to Cheyenne, Wyoming.
It was a 45 minute drive and I get shrimp
and lobster sauce and I'd get there
and I'd see 20 other New
Yorkers standing out there.
I don't know what this guy did.
Every New Yorker in Wyoming would
drive to this place on Fridays.
He's guy with cooked shrimp,
a lot of stuff. Uh, pork,
fried rice and an that
grow and it was delicious.
Did you ever see that episode
of Anthony Bourdain's show? Uh,
no reservations when he went to
Wyoming? Oh No, it wasn't Wyoming.
I'm confusing with Montana.
Montana is great too. Dog,
but that's fucking weather.
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
I camped there in October, in late
October. And how was it was terrible.
It was freezing.
It was fun though.
It was fun because it was something
new and something different. You know,
it's relatively safe as far as like
mountain lions go, there's no bears.
You don't have to worry about that.
So it was killed cold as fuck.
But relatively safe.
Montana is like,
it's still cowboy country. I mean it's,
it's really fascinating to speed limits.
Still crazy up there. Well, they didn't
have any speed limit for the longest time,
but the federal government
was like, listen, fuck off.
If you want any money at all from us,
you're going to put up
a fucking speed limit.
I remember there was those buoys to do
like 99 I had a buddy, Steve Graham,
Dr Steve, Dr Steve Lived in Montana. I
was 75 against fucking pedal it, but wow.
I used to fucking pedal up there,
fucking crank it to the,
it's basically the Autobahn billings.
Montana used to have like thinking about
holiday. Yeah. Once you pulled off,
it was right in the middle of town.
The Circle.
They still do call me their seats
200 it's a bar that stays in a hotel,
but I did that for triple
thousands of times. Oh,
I had the billings has a good vibe.
Collin and I landed and billings and we
had dinner in billings there the final
night and it seems like real nice,
real nice.
That's a place where you go where you
just don't want to move into Montana.
I'm gonna raise my kids.
What man? There's a,
there's a something about the people
that live that close to nature saying,
I felt the same way about anchorage.
You been in Alaska,
Goddamn anchorage is one of the
coolest places in the world.
There's something about being that close
to nature. It's like the people or more,
I want to say humble.
I want to say they're more grounded.
They're more grounded by whether they're
more grounded by just the intense
connection they have to nature. I mean
fucking eagles are everywhere up there.
I mean they see eagles all the time.
I saw like three or four eagles
while I was there. Like you,
you know what it's like to go 45 years
of your life. Never seen a fucking eagle,
and then all of a sudden you see a gang
of them. You're like, there's an eagle.
That's another eagle. One would fly
overhead. You're like, Holy Shit.
Look at the size of that fucking thing.
You see Moose up there.
We saw five Moose in two days.
Ari Shaffir and I did five Moose.
We caught these giant salmon that had come
out of the ocean and you know they're,
they're, they're, they're fucking swimming
up river to hatch and shit. We caught,
it was like we were just in
a real piece of wilderness.
We had to look out for bears. You have
to keep an eye out for fucking bears.
Joey Diaz.
It's the weirdest place ever.
But the Papel uh, we were not, no, we
didn't have anything other fish drink one.
Did you cook it right up? We
did one good. Oh, delicious man.
Delicious. We, most of
what we, uh, we caught,
we had to release that day because
of, uh, the numbers of the salmon.
We're it all depending on how many,
how many fish come through.
Like if they only have like
20 fish come through in a day,
they shut down the ability to
catch the fish and uh, keep them.
You have to catch and release.
But we caught one that was a rainbow
trout and a rainbow trout was,
oh my God, it was delicious. It was
so, because it's so fresh. I mean,
you're getting it like right from
this river. Oh, it's just the, this,
the majesty of that place, man. It's
incredible. It's, it's so, it's so weird.
It's so weird being up there because you
realize that this is how these people
live and it's so far removed from
anything you would experience in La.
Except I got to tell you some shit that
went down last night, man, listen to this.
You know I have chickens,
right?
So I go outside to shut the light out in
the chicken coop and the chickens, uh,
we keep the light on during the winter
months inside for a couple extra hours is
that they lay more eggs, they lay less
eggs when it starts getting darker.
And we were like, fuck you bitch, go
back to work, make some eggs. So anyway,
I go out to shut the light off and I
hear fucking running like a big heavy
animal running and it's,
I don't know what it is,
but I know it's big and I hear
but bone but up, up alone,
but a problem running through the grass.
And then I hear another one
chasing it and it's dark out,
but I'm near the hill and on the sea I
can see the silhouettes on the top of the
hill.
So as these things are running by,
I'm seeing them running by and I
don't know what the fuck it was.
I'm assuming that it was a deer.
This being chased by either
a coyote or a mountain lion.
If I was going to be my
on the fantastic side,
I'd lean towards the mountain line cause
I heard more than one heavy animal and
he could be that. There was just two
deer that were running away from some,
some coyotes we showing us here I, this
is fox in the chicken coop at night. Uh,
well they weren't trying to get in the
chicken coop. That's not what I'm saying.
They were, there's something was
chasing after this deer. It was,
these deer were running man.
They were running up hill full clip
and you could hear the trampling on the
ground and fucking leaves.
We're kicking up and it was no
more than a hundred feet from me.
So it was like some real live national
geographic shit cause whatever the fuck
that animal was was, it was running.
That's a least a 70 80 pound animal.
It was a big deer. It was a regular
size deer. It wasn't like a baby.
Whatever it is.
It was right.
I mean I'm saying I'm being real
conservative by saying seven.
It was probably a hundred pound deer.
So as it's running, but I'll put it on,
put it on pro. Did you hear this
other footsteps? And I'm looking at,
they all just ran by me, ran
by me, ran by me. And then um,
I did see a coyote,
a silhouette of a coyote on the horizon.
So it could have been the coyotes that
we're changing and the big animals could
have all just been deer.
Hard to tell because it was so dark out.
And I think what I saw was a coyote.
It was so hard to tell because
it was really dark and you know,
there was a little bit of moonlight
out in a little bit of lights from some
street lights and shit.
But it was just so freaky to see some
life and death shit taking place a hundred
feet from you. Just randomly. Like I
just randomly walked into a fucking gang,
hit an animal gang,
hit these fucking gangs at coyotes
or whatever the fuck it was.
One mountain line or the coyotes were
trying to kill someone that lives in the
neighborhood and eat them.
You need to get some night vision son,
get like a Sony camcorder
by the back door.
What I need to do is
get some game cameras.
They have game cameras that will go off
when they detect motion, you know, and uh,
we actually use them when we're
hunting big foot unsuccessfully.
But we did get a picture of an elk,
but that's what they're for. You know,
I would love to have seen
what the fuck it was.
Could you imagine if I had a cool video
of a mountain lion chasing down a deer
or even a pack of coyotes chasing
down a deer? Somebody's byline,
but obviously it'd be cooler,
but somebody was chasing a deer and I
was watching it all happen. It was nuts.
It was really freaky. Like, cause
it was a hundred feet from me.
[inaudible] problems, just fucking things
running behind like, Whoa, this is,
you know,
this is not what you expect to go out
to check and see if the chickens light's
still on. Yeah, it's
intense. It's pretty intense.
All that shit. I love it. I would shit
my fucking, I don't mind seeing that.
We were talking about that show the
at night for the most part it's you're
pretty safe.
It's just interesting as fuck that we
were discussing like Jira was that's found
the Moose and skin that took the liver
cause she was anemic and then they showed
the other guy walking from his house
until the wilderness eating fucking weeds
were a little bit of a food.
I mean they had like four
different stories going at once.
That was the most interesting shit I've
seen as a reality show in 20 fucking
years. It's a very interesting
show because it's not fake either.
They're not faking anything like,
oh no,
I lost my light or how I'm
going to say no, they're not.
They're not doing any of that.
The actual life itself that these people
living up there is so intense that it's,
it's worth just paying them to show
life below zero. Absolutely. Yeah.
To me it's one of the best of those
reality shows. I like the Alaska,
the last frontier.
That's another really good
families that are the
homesteading up there. And, uh,
that's a really fascinating show
because they seem like really,
really nice people.
Really cool like salt of the earth people
that are lit up there in Alaska and
like,
no one's a shithead Alaska.
The last frontier is the only show I've
ever seen on reality TV where there's no
enemy. Every person on
that show is a good person.
They're all very nice and very friendly.
They all seem to have a good sense of
humor. They seem to get along great.
They seem to be good natured. They seem
to all be hardworking. No one's lazy.
Everyone does their part,
but all they're doing their whole life
is stockpiling food and getting ready for
the big freeze. And it
fucking catches them for eight
months. So for eight months,
you can barely get around.
You could barely do anything.
It's fucking freezing for eight months.
So the four months outside of that,
it's all about gathering food.
So the whole show is about these people
catching fish or shooting a moose and
cutting it up or shooting a bear.
They're getting their food
entirely from the land.
I watched the episode with the White
Dude with the Indian wife and she's got
like dude with an Indian
wife and she's got what he,
she's got like three or four
kids. Oh, I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll,
I'll girls and a couple of boys and
they show them getting out of the boat.
She's an Eskimo, right?
She's said that's a good one.
Where they showed him setting up the
net so when the salmon come through that
could get them.
That was as interesting as I ever saw.
What was the most interesting?
So I mean,
not setting up the nuts was that they
involve the whole fucking family.
Everybody had where everybody was working,
everybody was wet,
fucking cut knives and trees and sweeping.
So that really fucking was like,
wow, that little kids had big ass
fucking kitchen. Don't have a job. Fish.
They have a job. Oh yeah,
like nothing. I'd be puking
at that fucker. It's intense.
It's intense. Yeah. And you know, I
thought that, ask him, I was a bad word.
I thought they decided that.
Ask Him I was bad.
And you're supposed to say [inaudible],
but she calls herself an Eskimo.
So I dunno. I Dunno. What's
the politically correct.
I'm fucked up Indian ESKIMO. Well,
it's not that far removed. You know,
that was a funny thing that came out of a,
there was a guy who was a rich dude
who was a Mormon who was absolutely
convinced that the Mormon doctrine was
true and that Joseph Campbell really was
correct, that the American Indians were
actually the lost tribes of Israel.
He's fucking, the dude just made shit up,
right? Joseph, that guy, Joseph Smith,
who created Mormonism is one of
the most hilarious characters.
And in all of recorded history when it
comes to like a guy who influenced the
large group of people to believe him,
because the stuff that he thought
was so wacky, it was so much of,
it was just so ridiculous.
But this was a big one that
the lost tribes of Israel
were the American Indians.
So this fucking guys,
I am going to prove that this is a true
story and the Mormon God is the only
guy,
whatever.
So this fucking guy spends a ton of
money to get the American Indian native
American, uh, genome identified.
It turns out they're from Siberia.
They all came down from the Bering strait.
Like all the native Americans, they,
they, they're very, very
similar genetically to
people that lived in Siberia.
It's pretty intense. We stop and
think about that, you know, I mean,
it's funny because there's this dummy
actually believed they were from Israel,
but, but it's, but it is fascinating
scientifically to think that they're all,
they were,
I love when scientists get it right
when they figured out that people walked
across the Bering strait and they made
it to North America, they're like,
they mapped it out there,
right? Like, yeah, look these,
you see these native Americans
there from Siberia to same folk,
same folk who came down that I like it
when they were right. It's fascinating.
It's fascinating to think that
they figured that out. You know,
they figured out how people got here
and who got here first is always under
debate. They're always finding some new
shit. They just found some shit in Zuni,
New Zealand.
They found a boat that was a a a
hundred years older than Captain Cook's.
So they're trying to figure out who
the fuck landed in New Zealand first.
Now imagine if he had to live back then.
Joey. Dan's traveling around by boat.
I could leave the fucking, have you
ever done a cruise? Do you work crews?
No.
Fuck working crews
thought about doing it back in the
day. Fuck No. In the hard times,
you wouldn't to take a good gig on a
cruise. Fuck me. Shoot me and shit.
I got to be in a boat talking to people.
You know what I do a show. They go,
I my home, I love boat. Nobody goes home.
Fucking cycles bumping into these
fucking knuckle heads wrapped the whole
fucking day. Hey, how you doing?
You're the one that insulted the
Christian God doing the afternoon.
I'm trying to get a son.
I just want to tell you that I
was offended by the captain. Yeah.
I told the captain and they should h I
was on a boat one time that big in the
80s. They still do. They
have a thing in New York. Uh,
the trip to nowhere and you
get on the boat six o'clock.
I know we all come to New York harbor
and they'd take you outside the city
limits and you could gam when you eat
like a big fuck the chicken the next day
he dropped you off at six in the
morning and everybody's good.
And I got sick for a little
while to take the pills.
I've been on boats like fishing boats a
lot and when I was a kid I was on every
summer and then in Miami and then I
started getting seasick when I was,
I got old. So one time I smoked
a fucking joint limitation.
Being seasick is bad enough.
Smoking weed and going on a boat on
the Jersey shore, that'll kill you.
What we freaking out.
I just went down on them but I got back
to the fucking boat and my friend kept
smoking. They joint, he's a savage, he's
out there fishing with one arm and shit,
smoking joints. He kept
saying to me, you're sure you
don't want to smoke anymore?
Cause I was out. We bought some
strong weed and Harlem. I was out.
It's one of the most uncomfortable things.
Yes,
but they'd been on a boat. Oh,
that's terrible. Something, you know,
being high and getting on
a boat or something and
something that you're not used
to. This time I got on a fucking bro.
I got an a fucking plane last week.
I got anxiety like a motherfucker.
When those little planes there was
a spooky spooky. Did you get out?
It was at a propeller one or was it
a a jet? A little jet. I didn't look,
I just sat there and looked straight
and sweating. Like fucking noise.
No, that's the one that connected fellers
Chicago to Nashville. I took it early,
early flight and I usually take
the 11 o'clock direct flight,
but I took the early flight and I want
it to Chicago and then I had a fucking
fly there and that little plane,
it's anxiety and they put you
in that little seat by yourself.
I was like in three Aa.
What?
It's weird that we rely on air travel to
get to do our job. But we do, you know,
both of us in a lot of ways.
More ways. I mean what else?
And people don't understand
that it's tough to travel.
I have just made it a simple
situation. So have you, we,
we've turned it into a situation that's
so not uncomfortable when you got to
make sure you don't do it too much.
That's one thing. Don't do too much.
You gotta know what too much is for you.
And if you start burning out from the
road, you got to back off. No, no, no.
I mean as far as like a planes,
like I know exactly what planes to catch.
Very seldom do I get delayed.
I know how to get a plane ticket now.
You know it first class isn't available.
I can't upgrade.
I know they get a thing for my ticket
so I could sweep to security and the
fucking whatever. Lynn, I just
put the thing in for pre Tsa.
Let's see if they approved me. Who the
fuck knows? It's good luck. Good luck
for long fucking time ago.
You know what I'm saying?
If you can't think of it was true,
but show the problem is people don't
look at it that way because most people
don't reform.
I mean,
how many people do you think that are
like hardcore criminals ever actually
fully reformed, kidnap and a couple
of burglaries and some drugs?
I ain't no terrorists.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm just a pimp trying to
make kids and that's it.
I ain't no fucking terrorist smell.
I see things from your perspective.
Clearly I love you,
but I also see things from the law
enforcement perspective like, hmm,
because this guy, I'm like,
are you fucking crazy?
He might not have ever gotten their
shit together. No, I understand.
But you know what I'm saying? You never
know. You never know when you have,
but I mean how many guys that we knew when
we were growing up who were criminals,
stayed criminals or wound
up dying. Oh No. I know.
Like everybody I knew
that was a crazy person.
Like they don't really fucking crazy.
Yeah, that was pretty fucking crazy.
I'm just not a criminal.
I'm still fucking up debt.
Do you think this because you
found an outlet in standup comedy?
It's just as exciting because I got
to think that a lot of the criminal
lifestyle is not just the fact
that you're trying to get by.
There's also a little bit of a charge
and getting away with shit. Absolutely.
For me, it was the charge. It was looking
at a motherfucker going to get what?
Not what you were talking about
all that shit. Now what? You know,
some guy run up to dog talking.
To me it was that,
but comedy outweighed the thrill of
doing that shit and more and more it just
stopped. Waited two, it became my love.
It became a passion and was like a,
it was like a see saw, you
know? It was like a seesaw.
Just kept switching and the love
kept Gretton me greater for common.
That put more emphasis on k,
you can't do comedy in jail.
You could do comedy here.
If you sit around the fucking thing
with a bunch of brothers and jump up and
down,
but you can't do comedy in jail.
Did you also start to feel like with
comedy, you know you're, you're, you're,
you're feeling that excitement,
but a positive result is coming out of it.
Everybody's having a good time,
you're having a good time,
they're having a good time.
No one feels bad about it after it's over.
Whereas when you do something criminal,
there's always going
to be a bit of remorse.
You're always gonna
think you'll justify it,
but there's always going to be a bit of
remorse that you've resorted to stealing
or hurting people or we all know. I think
inherently that's not the way to go. No,
but you,
you,
you and I are very smart in ways that
we saw something that a lot of people
didn't see. Even though we love
something you loved fighting till today,
you still love fighting,
but you thought about your life
at the age of 50 and you said,
I want to be able to pick up kids.
I want to be able to remember my name
and there's no, even with football now,
now we're seeing it more with football
with me. I know one thing for sure.
I know one thing for sure, and we'll sit
here too. We find me. Name me a mobster,
a criminal, a gangster that made
millions and then Diana can or get shot.
Let me tell you something.
There's nothing worse than living
your life like a pimp. I mean,
you're 51 get a knock on your
door and now when your old days,
you've told me a thousand times
how much you fear getting older,
not being able to take care of yourself.
You think of being 50 to the feds come in,
they take everything.
There's nothing left after those
vultures come and they put you in a,
they put you in a cage and you get shitty
food and your family has to fend for
themselves now and they got a reputation.
Now these people can't
live in the neighborhood.
They can't live in a gated community.
They were married through.
I always knew that the end result,
I had an uncle who I loved as a kid and
I would go to Miami and my mom would
send me to Miami for a summer.
My mom didn't let me fucking stay
in New York those early days.
In the summer I would go to
Miami and he built the northwest.
He built the southwest.
He was a construction guy and he was like,
guys we grew up with, he was a heavy
guy that did the whole job himself.
He was the GC, he dug it, he laid the
pipe, he did the brick work, the war,
and he became this thing. It became a
millionaire. But you know, he used to do,
every summer he'd drive out hand and
fucking camper with his kids and stuff the
bottom with. We didn't go back to
Miami and I guess one something.
He shot a motherfucker and I knew
this guy. You know, when I was a kid,
when I was a kid at night,
he would take me and we'd go on a boat
and we'd go out to Miami and he pulled
him the weed and then we'd
go to a warehouse and we
dropped the weeder and we go
to the next day we'd get
back to his room of our five,
cause his wife and him
didn't sleep in the same bed.
So I would hang out with my cousins.
There were three of them,
and I would sleep in the room with him.
And at one after tea,
women in the old days, the TV shut
off at one once, mission impossible,
turning off the pledge of allegiance
came on and he would go, go, get, go,
get ready, and we'd get ready to go
to Lubbock. He thought like he goes,
those little stores in Miami that you
pull through when you buy a beer and a
thing of milk and eggs and he'd take a
beat and we drive to the boat and he'd
get on the boat when I
was seven and we pull out,
he pulled in the wheat and then we'd go
back and then we'd go back and the next
day I go play with the kids
and I couldn't say nothing.
And he trusted me because he knew
that I knew what my mother did.
But one day when I was down there,
one summer they knocked on his fucking
door and they arrested him and I was done
and I had to go home.
And then my mother told me what happened.
He shot a guy like in the sixties
and now it's the 70s and he says,
backing on target practicing
and some guy in a new development eight
miles away is walking his dog and he
shoots and the bullet keeps going
to hit him in the fucking leg.
He goes to the hospital,
they take it out, they scan.
It's the same bullet that shot the
guy in California 10 years earlier.
This motherfucking,
the height of his story with his kids,
seven to 10 has to sell everything,
move his kids to a two bedroom in Atlanta.
Meanwhile,
he had a house
like fucking, you know, 10 bedrooms.
He had to move his kids wetland or the
attorney had to do eight fucking years.
He came out when he was 64 and what
happens when you come out when you're 64
broke? There's nothing. He died and I,
last time I talked to him was
during the tornado in Miami.
He was living in a fucking trailer.
That lesson taught me right
there that that's not the way,
you know what I'm saying? I'd rather
have a hard life and then it gets easy.
And then when you're 60 or
70 you live like a doctor.
You want to play with your grant,
you want to look at the back.
So I saw the same future. You thought
you saw it, you saw what the ending is.
Yeah. I could end up on CBS sports,
but that's 22% of those people.
The other 68 whatever percentage number
is they ended up in the hospitals.
They can't remember that name.
You know what I'm saying? Well,
I was lucky that martial arts
didn't have a venue back then.
There wasn't a professional venue
because when I was 21 years old when I,
I think I had my last fight or they're
21 or 22 but I remember thinking,
where's this going?
Like they had offered me a pro kickbox
and fight for like 500 bucks or something
like that. And I was like, okay,
well I got to train for like six weeks
to make 500 bucks. Like that's crazy.
And I know that this is like,
like a first fight that it was like,
well how much the champions make.
Sorry,
I found out this kid in Rhode Island
that was the world champion and a,
I was asking people trains on them. I
go, is this, is this guy, is he well off?
Like how does he do? He said they got
bro, if he, he's lucky if he's lucky,
he'll make $1,000 for a fight. And I
was like, what? And they were like,
there's no money in this. And I was like,
okay, what am I doing? What am I doing?
I'm either going to get hit in the
head in taekwondo tournaments for free
because there's zero professional
outlet or I'm going to do kickboxing,
which I was already sort
of at a disadvantage at
because I didn't start off my
career kickboxing.
So to transition from taekwondo in the
kickboxing was going to take a little
while for me to really get it down. I was
getting better with my hand techniques,
but fucking headaches, man.
I would get head aches wide.
I'd lie in bed and know that my head
was throbbing because Dude's had punched
it.
I just had taken shots in the head and
kicks and punches and you're fucking
skulls.
Getting rattled around in there am
alone in my shitty apartment in Medford.
Lying on a mattress,
looking up at the ceiling going,
am I breaking my brain like am I,
am I,
am I going to irreversibly
break my brain doing this shit?
Training for kickboxing tournament
fighting three times in a day for nothing,
finding for nothing. There was no
money at all. There was no money.
I came in second place in this kickboxing
tournament, there wasn't a dime,
which is crazy. Violence
for free, you know,
and I thought about it and I was like,
there's only one option.
I have to get out of this for our break
myself because I can keep going and
maybe I could achieve some
goals and started school.
But I had known at that point that I
wasn't going to be a very good selective
teacher because I didn't want to
teach anybody who wasn't crazy.
Like if you didn't want to go to war,
well I'm really not
interested in teaching you.
I didn't want to do any aerobics classes.
I didn't want to.
I wanted to teach people who want to
learn with every ounce of their being.
I want to teach people who are
obsessed like I was. I'm like,
if you want to do this, you've
got to do, this is dangerous.
There's people like me out there,
they're going to try to kick your
fucking head off your neck for real,
and if they hit you, you're
fucked. And if you keep going,
you're going to wind up on the opposite
side of a ring with one of those fucking
guys,
and it's going to be a guy who is gonna
try to kill you and you've got to try to
kill him.
And that's the game.
And you want to learn that
this is what we've got to do.
And if you don't do it my way,
if you don't do it the way that I've been
taught and the way that my instructors
have been taught and the
way that everybody agrees
is the right way to do it.
I don't want to do it. I don't want to
hear any cramp talk. I don't want to hear,
I'm tired. I don't wanna hear
shit. I want you to keep,
I want you to force your body to work.
And if you can't do that, we can't talk.
That's terrible for business.
I didn't want to advertise.
I didn't want to put up fliers.
I only wanted to get the
hardest core dudes and women
that were willing to fight.
One of my best students was a chick
that I started out from a white belt and
broader all the way up to a really strong
blue bell about to get her red belt,
which is right before black and
talk window and she was bad ass man.
I taught her from white belt onto a
onto like the into higher ranks and she
would just dominated tournament's
man. His chick was crazy. She was,
but she absorbed it. She was
like a sponge. She would come in,
there'd be all these hardcore people
training and she just got right into the
mindset. All these people that have
trained with me and that were ahead of me,
like my friends like Leroy Rodriguez and
Larry Jones and all these like the top
level national black belts,
all lived in this Boston area and they
would all train together and come down.
We would train with each other and
bring students in and the ones that were
obsessed, man, they were fun. The ones who
really wanted to get better, they just,
you could see them just with
every technique they through.
They got a little bit better
at it every fucking day.
That got a little bit better and you see
them stretching and working on it and
it's an exciting, but then if you see
someone who's like half ass in it,
it's brutal. It's hard. I can't
do it. I can't, I can't, you know,
if they're not totally into it,
I completely understand.
But I don't want to be teaching you.
You have to be a crazy person.
If you're a crazy person,
I'll teach you
out of the corner.
For me,
there's a show to come of school
and I go for walks at night.
I like going to that
Watson 13 to 15 year old,
I realized how many was
that waste doing cottage,
how many fucking I was that way.
That's a big point of controversy in
the martial arts community. Cod is,
and you know what I got
good at when I was a kid,
I would go to those dumb tournament's
in New York and I won first place in
college. But in those days there
was no full contact. There was oh,
semi contact from the waist
down, you know, for the waste.
And I would always get
disqualified for punching.
Everybody does that then. Yeah, then I
go home late. Fucking cod is did we do,
because now if you know the Catia,
they'll promote you.
It's not like it was that then as well.
It's not that in Jujitsu. No, no, no.
It's uh, it's, that's how I got my
first strike when you just seven months.
It took me seven months dog,
but I did it and I'm just doing G.
I'm horrible at them. No. Geetha
[inaudible] hey, it's fine.
You just getting to enjoy the
actual numbers. I swung on people.
I fucking, you already have a
lot of knowledge, man. You know,
you have more than the average person in
the conversations you've had with Eddie
and with Michelle talks talking,
he's one of the best in the world.
He's one of the best
instructors in the world.
I'm just show the way
he breaks things down.
I'm so bad at the Noguchi
and grabbing people's neck.
I got bits pro and I get rid of this
time and if you lose more weight,
the more weight you lose, the
ability to get. Yeah, you just,
let me tell you something got melt
off being in shape and there's been in
Jujitsu shape, I can't go more
than twice a week. It destroys me.
So I tried to go on Tuesdays, on
Thursday days, the guys a, I go to v Mac,
but it's a John jock school.
I wanted to keep it in the family.
It's in north Hollywood.
It said John Jack Black Belt Marcello,
but they have a could bring your black
belt that teaches a purple about and he's
fucking tremendous. Joe Rogan, you know,
I've always been a fan of just straight
Jiu Jitsu. I liked the UFC, but for me,
I love watching these videos.
I've watched that Brazil video probably
easy 500 times for the last two years.
I watch all of Marcello Garcia is how
to escape from the fucking side control.
I love all his three escapes.
I love all that shit have and
I'm fans of certain people.
I really like Stephen Caplin.
I really like his stuff.
He's a big white guy from Canada teachers.
Some basic stuff online.
It's amazing how much you
could get online. Oh yeah,
like you could be in shape,
but then this digital shit like now I
can do HIPAA escapes just down one side.
I can't do back and forth yet, but when I
would go, those things are hard, but not,
when I go to a hotel and I do comedy,
I go to the thing I run and
I do hip escapes. I do him
in a hotel now that's it.
You could get a real good workout
with body weight. You the hotel. I do.
If I just want to just do
something to say I did something,
I do a hundred bodyweight squats and a
hundred Hindu pushups and that really
gets your heart going, man.
100 body weight squats.
When you started hitting
like 70 and 80 like, whoa,
this is fucking like
your legs are burning.
You have to take big deep breaths
and completed and you can do it,
but it's you feel it and
then a hundred Hindu pushups.
It's the same thing when you're in like
Hindu pushup number three like bitch,
I'll do a hundred of my sleep.
But then you start getting like
towards 70 and you're like Ugh,
you're by the time I do a hundred of
each, I've got a decent, you know,
15 minute workout in.
It's like it's something real isn't
that gets your heart pumping. Yeah,
it's just what they bought and then
supplement that with some set ups.
Do some pushups and you could get like a
rock solid workout in a hotel room with
no room at all easily. Nice. Very nice.
But I like everything that everything's
a nice and easy and cheap to do.
A lot of body weight stuff these days.
A lot of body weight stuff,
a lot of body weight squats
and a lot of Chin ups.
I do a lot of like look all the way
down Chin ups all the way down like this
slow cause
I think that's like motion that
is replicated in Jiu Jitsu.
Like pulling a body synching up a choke,
like trying to pull someone in,
grabbing a gable grip, trying
to complete a sweep. You know,
that's a lot of like slow polling and
it's like a long range of motion type
thing.
Like sometimes you grab and people from
way out here and you're trying to suck
them in and out.
So I think that Chin ups and
things along those lines,
like things that make your
body like functionally strong.
I think those are really under underrated.
A lot of people want to lift weights,
you know, they just want to fucking
tell you. They like dude's telling me,
I put up three 15 for
four okay, what? Whatever.
What can you do with that body?
You've got a Ferrari that you
don't know how to drive. You know,
you get this crazy race car,
you can even take a first corner,
you fall on your head. You're
not an, you're not athletic.
Like you're not even using this
like to get good at a sport.
You don't do any sports.
He just lift like a crazy meathead.
Like you've got to do
something with that shit.
You're not gonna know how to use it.
Three 15 three 15 dumb.
My goal at the end of this year,
there's three 15 for five,
they high five each other
and they secretly think about
cock slap acids and just
fucking,
maybe
when I first moved to Colorado, the
guys next door to me with fucking lift,
you know,
just fucking insane amounts and they
would shoot deca and just keep lifting.
And that's all they did. I couldn't
figure out, like I would go down, man,
watch this.
The form was great.
They mixed up bodybuilding with strength
techniques like dead lifts that had
squats and uh,
and they did bodybuilding shit.
Jesus Christ on a crutch. Uh, I
was just laughing at something.
What were you laughing by?
Spilled coffee on myself.
You're talking about your friend who
used to have his mom shoot him with
steroids while he was doing the
line and he was on the phone
fucking Costa coffee all over my
cause the podcast, every six weeks,
they'll bad if he's still
alive. He's still alive.
That's what I'm talking about.
And you know, the guy I kidnap probably
called the podcast, right? Told me
that is so ridiculous.
Six years later,
he accepted the apology and he calls me
from time to time though, says hello,
how are you? When I lived in
revere, when I was kickboxing,
when I was teaching that a nautilus plus
there was a kid he used to work out at
Nautilus plus I became friends with,
if he's listening to this, I forgot,
I forgot his name, I'm sorry. But we
were friends for like a year or so.
Very nice guy. But anyway, he was
fucking huge. He was like my age.
We were both like around 21 but
he wished fucking gigantic. Like,
I don't know how much you weighed,
but I was like,
I was fighting at one 60 at the time.
So I was probably about 160 plus pounds
and he was maybe 200 and we were about
the same height.
And the dude was just fucking swole,
like looked way different than me.
I got a giant ass neck and giant shoulder.
It looks different than me right now.
He was just this big bodybuilder dude.
And uh, I didn't know what
he did. I didn't, I didn't,
I was totally ignorant
to steroids back then.
Totally ignorant because I was
always trying to lose weight.
I was not thinking about lifting
weights and getting any bigger.
I was trying to like
compete at 154 pounds,
so in taekwondo and then one 16
kickboxing. But I, I asked him once,
we were driving somewhere and I go, uh,
so what do you eat? And he goes, uh,
he goes, ah, you know, I
have about a, you know,
80% protein breakdown and this and that
and that and this. And I said, now,
and what kind of supplements you
take. And so he tells me, you know,
I take a little bit of this,
a little bit of that this is really
good for your metabolism. And I said,
do you do any steroids? And
there's a pause. And he goes, dude,
fucking look at me.
What do you think?
Of course they do steroids.
And I was like, oh, okay.
But it was like the most hilarious
conversation because he just like,
looks at me. He goes,
dude, fucking look at me.
Who's world?
What's that?
American gladiator star nitrile you just
had a heart attack and he blames it on
a roid abuse. Wow. I balked at
all. All we did for 30 years.
It's the blow. That's the
issue. That's Shane del Rosario,
who was a UFC fighter that died
of a heart attack recently. Uh,
he was a very cool guy by the way,
in a really good fighter and a very good
kickboxer before. So terrible tragedy.
This guy died of a heart attack,
but apparently they released the coroner's
results and he had opiates in his
system and cocaine. So, you know, it was,
who knows what caused it.
But he also had a condition
that he was born with, you know,
that uh,
it was some sort of a,
a heart condition that he
had that was just genetic.
So is that on top of the other stuff?
But the coke is what gives people fucking
heart attacks bad. It's just something,
did you ever hang with
anybody who, I mean, hey,
like on a daily basis that steroids was
their world. You don't have to see the,
the wrestling. No, he goes to buy the
juice and the guy says to him, right,
I gave you two ounces of this.
You know, whatever vials of that
when you were in somebody's world.
It's like, that is fucking insane.
It was just a different dimension.
Well, you know what, it's like man.
It's like anything.
It's like gun nuts.
You ever talked to a gun
nuts about calibers? Well,
like the 50 cal with a seven millimeter,
the five six 7:00 AM they start talking
to these crazy numbers is 700 wind mag
and you don't know what the fuck they're
saying. It's you get confused. Well,
I've got a three Oh eight I got a two
seven eight 22 caliber is a part of those
are the bullet goes at
350 feet per second.
Like how the fuck do you know all this?
They become dorks. They become gun dorks.
Like my friend Justin, very cool
dude. 100% gun dork. He's a gun door.
We have conversations and I say that
with all due respect and love because I
love talking to him about God.
It's fascinating because I love talking
to people about anything that they're
super passionate about. And this
motherfucker is passionate about guns.
He's got a ton of guns, he does
competitions, he goes and does,
you know those room clearing competitions
where target's pop up and you shoot
out a pink pink, you know, they, they
do all these, you know, scoring events.
So he, he loves that Shit. So he'll,
he'll talk to me and you know,
if he'll get as Geeky as I let them, you
know, like if I go, we'll keep going.
Well what does that mean? You
know, he'll just keep going.
I mean he knows everything there is about
loads and balances and impact and who
makes the fucking most precise rifles.
And it's like anything else,
they do it about steroids. They do it
about guns, someone to do it about boats.
They'll start telling you about the
fucking best kind of of, of, of,
of a hand carved wooden
canoe you could buy.
They have to buy to run it from a very
specific type of wood and it has to be
cured in a certain way.
There's two manufacturers
still do it by hand. You know,
there's guys that are the W
it's that way with everything.
There's always some people that are
completely fucking obsessed with whatever
the subject is. If it's
steroids, if it's MMA,
how many fucking guys have you ever
talked to that are like complete total MMA
history buffs like Joe Silva?
Let me tell you something.
I know a lot about MMA.
I know a lot of fights.
I got a lot of fights in my memory.
He's probably got doubled the
amount of fights in his memory.
This motherfucker will tell me
like if he and I will be talking,
there's a new guy that's brought into
the UFC and I'll say, what's his deal?
What does he do? Joe Silva has seen this
guy fight 20 times already probably.
And uh,
he'll,
he'll just rattle off with his
strengths and weaknesses are what he's
susceptible to.
What I would do if I was fighting them.
And nine times out of 10
he's on the money's on the D.
I mean that guy is
obsessed with MMA obsessed.
When I lived in Boulder,
I had a problem,
my ex wife and one of the first people
I ever met in boulder at a we'd place,
I was living on the hill. The hill is
where the University of Colorado is.
I was living a block away,
not even 10 12 14th street and
next to me was the wheat chick.
She was 80 and her boyfriend was 20 they
were then asked his father really 80
had to be 50 something ugliest woman
he'd ever seen in your fucking life.
This kid was like both deadheads.
They both smoked like death. He,
his father invented like the
belly button ring or something.
He was a millionaire. He got money every
month. I found out they sold the weed.
I used to go with that bye week and every
time I was over there there was this
lanky,
skinny dude named Ed
and I used to talk to Adam and
immediate at all. He was from Boston,
me and that hit it off and I
didn't know where that didn't.
Everyday I see it on the hill and I
talked to Ed. This is 1985 brother. Right.
And I loved that. And finally I
let her know what I did. You know,
I used to do credit cards then
and they told me, you know,
we became friends and it was a
Vietnam vet, but he was alert.
He was the one that went and cleaned up.
You fucked up. He went and cleaned up.
But there was another loop.
There was a couple, it's alert.
What does this term something that's bad,
like these guys are bad,
like danger bat, a cleaner,
like a cleaner, bad, like
it's just this bad news.
The guy you call when the shit
hits the fan, the cards and shit,
they're the ones that left the cards and
Vietnam when they shot you let the ace
of spades or some shit so alert.
He had a buddy who was named was like,
he had like a weird name and that
guy thought he was the devil.
And I had heard this from other
people that that guy and he,
they all bought weed at this house and I
became friends with him over the years.
I became friends with that and I knew ed
was a stone cold killer when I went to
the vet thing with him Monday,
I gave him a ride to the vet
thing and on the walls that Bro,
there were pictures of him with kids and
Purple Stars and metals and I'm like,
are you fucking serious? So I thought
that was a good heart of the American,
you know, bro, ed was a great guy.
He was my brother. If he's listening,
I haven't talked to him in 20 years.
I love him and I miss him.
But it was a stone cold killer.
I made the mistake of telling that I had
a problem with somebody and every time
I'd see that we'd smoke a joint
and then the third puffy go,
so what are we going to kill that guy?
And he wasn't kidding.
So the guy that thought
he was a devil was rock.
That's what he used to call himself.
Rod was dying from Agent Orange.
And I guess him and Ron were doing fucking
bangs on the side, like hitting me.
I didn't know this and
I'm like [inaudible], but
every time I see Eddie go,
what's up dog? And he hugged me
and I loved him. He was my brother,
but I knew he was serious. He was like
wanting to be taken out, that dude.
And every time I'd see
him his plan changed.
Like he had been thinking about
this and finally he's like, listen,
I got the cones, we're going
to let him pull out a baseline.
These motherfuckers want to pull them
out of the car and baseline in boulder,
like Willis that cones up like we're
firemen and when he comes by at nine 18
we're going to pull him out of the car.
And that whole plan was like, I was like,
what are you going to shoot him when
he goes, Bro, we don't shoot people.
I told you this. He goes,
we're going to shoot me.
We take them up until those hills be
titles motherfuckers out and we just
wrapped with peanut butter and we come
back three days later and it's Geesa.
All they find is like a little elbow on
the floor. She's and she goes to bed.
I mean these guys are fucking serious.
The parents just eat every time I'd
see him after that dog was that scary.
You don't want to do this joy, joy.
Let me take care of just for you.
You're my friend. I love you. I mean,
that's how it got. This was like,
I've been around some crazy people and
that's why I respect Colorado so much.
So this day there's some fucking animals
walking around those weeds prompt in
boulder and I loved that.
I mean I bro,
if I introduced you to that and you met
at Edward, drop shit on you that you go,
go, your friends are fucking
genius. What the fuck's,
he never talked about
weapons. Never. You know,
he never told you cause a Vietnam vet.
He never took them a month and a half
to tell me how to drive them to the
fucking vet place to get
medication. The real deal. Yeah.
There's some crazy people out there.
That's why I love the fuck
fucking comes up to you and goes,
what's this guy's number?
Let me go down there and smack the
shit out of Pauly shore. You know what?
I'm saying there's people that will
do it. Actually they just wait. No,
don't please don't.
I just said Pauly shore.
I don't know what you shouldn't say
Paul. I've got no problem. Sure.
But it's fucking this people out there
with their fucking phone on speed dial
ready to attend.
The funny thing is I had a friend who
was the same way about steroids and he's
dead too.
And I hung out with him and this is a
little steroid crew and it was fucking
amazing. The lingo, the
lingo they threw around.
What's the way you and I discussed
sets going to Boston for the weekend,
doing two shows, how great it was.
This motherfuckers like, Nah dog.
I get up in the morning
and do a protein shake.
It's like blast off a little deck and
then when I come out I take 10 tablets,
a deep ball, those tablets of five
milligrams, like people would go do one.
These guys are doing tech. We had a Jean
Le Ballon podcasts, you know judo gene,
well famous, famous for not just
as martial arts, but it stunt work,
did a lot of stonework and he was telling
us there was a guy that he used to be
friends with a died from steroids who
used to shoot up every 30 minutes and he
said every 30 minutes he would disappear,
would go into his bathroom.
He hit himself with something else.
It was just doing different shit all day,
more than 300 pounds.
The jeep was named Jeep Swenson.
Do you remember Brian?
Cheap Swenson
bodies for arms.
There was like a body that was his arm,
this thing when I hung out with them and
I miss him, but I remember how you said,
tell me the last shot I do
is Fridays to go workout.
I go down the show, I do some blow, I
drink some beers, eat some burger king.
When I come back Sunday, I look in
the mirror by boom, let's back it up.
That's the guy,
Jesus Christ.
That's not even a person anymore.
Where's the fucking barbarian?
But the best of the people
who denied doing steroids.
You have a friend that came up to
me the shoot and he said to me,
how you doing Joe Rogan ever tell
you about me? The guy is ginormous.
A black dude box APP. I don't know what
his name, the guy from the pride? No,
no, no. He's not a fighter. Okay.
He's an actor. Okay. He goes,
I'm a friend that Joe Rogan's. Did He
tell you about me? I go, no. He goes,
I was on fear factor. Big Black
Body, but you're very, very nice guy.
Him and his buddy were were
both bodybuilders and they
were competing and they
got, they got their
ass kicked. I did some,
I did some movie with them and the people
like, so do you do steroids? He's like,
I'd never done steroids in my life.
He would say the barbarian brothers again,
we go back to the barbarian brothers
please, whether by Barry and buzz,
I want to smack the shit
out of both of them.
They used to say that they
never did steroids. They
just ate 36 eggs a day. Well,
it depends on what kind of
steroids is shoot into your ass.
I mean, I guess it's the,
what are your chickens?
Chickens are fucking terror birds running
around your backyard. Well, you know,
those guys,
like if I'm looking at that picture,
I could believe that either one of
those guys didn't take steroids.
If you had a good genetic disposition,
if you have good, uh, mesomorphic
jeans and you really power lift hard,
he can get that big. My
friend Brian Frazier, I always
tell the story because, uh,
Brian,
uh,
who is a comic and writer wrote for
a bunch of different different shows.
But,
um,
he was at one point in time a serious
bodybuilder and he never did a steroid in
his life, 100%. I know for a fact
that all he did was eat good food. He,
he actually would pride
himself on the fact that, uh,
he wouldn't take supplements.
He would get all this food for
vegetables and meat and stuff like that.
But he was fucking huge and he
was a hundred percent natural.
He was just obsessed. That motherfucker
was at the gym every day. And he was like,
like one time he went on stage
and after the show I go, dude,
you can't wear short sleeves. You got
stop doing that. He goes, why? I go,
you're too big. I go, it's too
distracting. I go, you freaked me out.
And we're friends like, are you fucking
huge dude? You can't just, I mean his,
his arms like he,
everything that he would wear would be
like tight to his arms like that because
his arms were literally double
the size of my arms. They were,
he was a huge guy and it was all natural.
I'll tell you what I'm here to tell you.
Huh?
Do you say you think this right here is,
I mean that looks super steroid. Yeah,
that was 1982 I want to see him today,
but Brian was close to that size.
No bullshit.
But the discipline that Brian Frazier
has is like, he's a crazy person.
He's got like a radical
amount of discipline.
Oh. And I got a laptop. I'll argue this
point while the guys are doing with eight,
seven,
six years,
I was the stock clerk in the kitchen after
I almost blew it up. Don't making the,
the, the fucking cinnamon
donuts, the cinnamon things.
I made them too big and they fired me.
And part of my Gig was hiding
steroids for a lot of the inmates.
A lot of the epics.
We get steroid in vix.
He's one of my favorite
words that you use. Yeah.
The inmates would fucking get, you know,
and they would get a nothing, I'm sorry.
Nothing would syringes. It was an NFR.
And uh, there was another one when stroke,
when he fee when strove veep pills, three
milligrams of a milligram and a half.
That was big in that. And what
these savages would do, you know,
I knew who was doing steroids,
but there were some black guys,
I've been locked up for 10 years and had
families that couldn't afford fucking
steroids and they would,
uh, they would, uh,
these guys were yolked show and they'd
been getting yoked. And when I say yoked,
you know, low fat, low, low, not
a lot of fat, little rip to him.
And they were doing this for
prison food. Terrible. No protein.
I don't fucking know what happened. Well,
you could buy protein powder, right?
You can order protein powder
and there was all vegetables.
You get Broccoli and lettuce. It's,
it's, it's burger king letters.
It's the same shit. They give you a
burger king in that fucking cheeseburger.
You know, it's not, it's a Nicaraguan
shit. It's nothing to share rock. Yeah.
It's not let us that
when you bite into it,
it's fresh.
But these guys were getting
yoked in there on protein powder,
like Joe Wieder protein powder,
you know, when it was back then.
Now there's still a huge, oh
my God, that guy's huge. Yeah.
No steroids in my ass. And Yeah, there's
no question. But I'm telling you,
my friend Brian was pretty close to that
size. We did a gig together and, um,
I want to say Vermont, Vermont and
New Hampshire, one of those. And uh,
he had a bit of a cold. He didn't
like, his voice is really rasping.
And uh, after the show he had a great
set, but after the show he apologized,
the club owner, he was just
real conscientious about
shit like that. He goes,
I'm really sorry, my voice
has been bothering me all
week. And the guy was like,
don't worry about it. Listen, you killed
it was a great show. And he goes, uh,
he goes, I just, I just feel like it
wasn't my best performance on just so,
you know, I just want to apologize.
And the guy was like, Hey,
will you stop being a Jew about it?
He didn't know that my friend was Jewish
because Brian doesn't live Jewish.
She's blonde. He looks like, um, like a
a Midwest football guy. He looks like,
you know, he's got blond curly hair.
He's says big fucking sick nick gorilla.
And the guy calls him a Julie says it,
stop being a Jew about it.
He just thought that he was being
cute. He's trying to be funny. He goes,
I am fuck Jewish and you know his
face gets red and then fuck you,
you fucking racist piece of shit.
You antisemetic Cock sucker.
Like he'd just like totally takes it like
to like level 10 and the guy was like,
hey, calm down. It was just a,
just an expression of speech.
Like he's leaning over this guy's death.
The only thing that's saving him as
the fact there's a desk between them,
you know,
otherwise Brian,
we're probably got directly in his face
and the guy might've swung at a just
sheer panic or who knows what the fuck
could happen and while I'm watching this
I'm, I'm like, what am I going to do?
Like he's way stronger than me. I can't,
I can't grab him. I'm not going
to hit him. He's my friend.
I don't know what to do cause
it looked like he was like,
he was a gorilla and I'm like,
I can't keep him off this guy.
If he decides to get on this guy,
I don't know what to do here.
And he just calmed down at the last
minute was like fuck two takes his check.
And fucking stormed out of
there and I tell the guy, well,
I don't think you're going
to say that again. Sorry.
The guy didn't know what to do.
He was shitting his pants.
He was an older guy too, you know he was,
he was, he was legitimately terrified.
Brian was an enormous, I mean,
wasn't going to hurt the guy.
I'd never known him to
do anything violent ever,
but goddamned he scared the fucking
shit out of this dude. He just,
you'd never expect that he was Jewish.
She didn't look Jewish at all. You know,
you think of Jewish, you think a
dark haired people. Where is he?
I don't know why he's doing,
he was out here for awhile.
I ran into him once in a movie
theater a few years back now.
I think he was just writing at the time.
It's funny dude though.
You get to see anchorman two yet.
You know, I bought a joke from him.
He's the only,
there's two dudes ever about a joke from,
and he's one that I never used it,
but I've talked about it on the podcast.
He was a heckler line that
he created and he goes,
this is my impression of God creating you.
Okay.
Just a of current. Oh No. The
cap came off too much content.
I've ruined it.
And he needed money at the time.
So what you, and he says like, I'll
devastate on stage. So he sold it to me.
I think it was 500 bucks. Whoa. It's
worth it. That's a lot of money. Hey Dude,
needed some money. I thought it was
a great line. It's worth 500 bucks.
That's a great line for me. I never
even never used it on stage. I mean,
maybe I used it once. I can't
remember. I going to go pee real quick,
but it's one of the few
things I've ever paid for.
There's a werewolf in the new anchorman.
I just wanted to let you know very well.
Well, now I'm in. I was going to
be in any way. It looks hilarious.
The fucking ads look awesome.
Yeah. It looks like the perfect,
get baked and see a silly movie.
Definitely get really, really? Yeah. Yeah.
You have to get really big though.
It's super ridiculous and if you liked
the first one, you'll love this one,
but there's so many good cameos in it.
And when I saw that Werewolf
transformation, I'm just like,
oh Joe's and shit is fucking, you
just ruined it for everybody, man.
Spoiler alert you son of a bitch.
The anything will Ferrell does on man,
that guy kills me man.
Talladega nights is still one of
my all time favorite comedies.
Just for the sheer ridiculousness
of it all. It's like,
I love that kind of comedy.
Like a guy who was like a complete total
buffoon who was like a goodhearted guy
who fucks everything up.
Last night I got to see David
Arquette do standup comedy.
He came into the comedy store and
just like bye and he's like everyone,
everyone's uh, bill was on me like he
paid for everyone's drinks last night.
Like a lot of fucking people there too.
That's interesting. Why did he do that?
I don't know. He's just holidays I think.
I think he comes in once in a while,
but then he went on stage and did
like a little little set and it was
interesting. But you know, I
didn't see the whole thing.
But it's hard to do stand up after
you're already famous, you know? I mean,
especially when you're known for
doing comedy movies and you know,
and then you try to create your own stuff
and go on stage with it in that form
and it's so, that's also so raw when
you got to think of a guy like that.
It's so insulated from regular
people in like a performance setting.
Everything he performs gets put out
there on television or in the movies and
he's not there when it,
when the people are seeing it.
David Arquette guy being an actor,
comedy actor. But I'm saying like the,
the transition between doing that and
doing stand up in front of a live audience
and a small place like the comedy store,
that's a big goddamn transition
that's hard to do. There's a lot of,
it's really interested in seeing how
many like uh, actors and musicians,
what just try stand up comedy.
They just come to the comedy store one
day and next thing you know John Mayer's
on stage. Well you know
what man, they can do it.
It's not like we could do
a open mikes from music.
You imagine we showed up at open much
music and just started singing fucking
terrible.
So we are the world like we are
the world like Bruce Springsteen
be all serious about it. I think if
you do one of those open Mike Nights,
you probably have to do your own
music, right? You have to be original.
I don't know.
I would imagine that'd be ridiculous
unless it's a really old song and then
you're doing like a bad ass cover of it
where you like wiggle it around a little
bit, change it to little Dwight
Yoakam doing Elvis, that kind of shit.
I guess you'd get away with that.
I always thought it was really cool when
Johnny Cash did hurt by nine inch nails.
Yeah, that sounds like one. He picked
a nine inch nails song, but two,
he made it his own.
He was like,
it seems like it was his song rusty cage
by sound garden until we did a couple
of times. Yeah. Yeah.
And hurt dude is might one of my
favorite Johnny Cash songs ever. Yeah.
Just because he was so fucking
old when he did that, that video,
that song and that video were done when
he was, he knew he was on his last days.
That guy lived hard.
That was the real crazy road life.
The Rock and roll life,
those kinds of trends of stars.
Shit Dude.
Those country stars back in the day I
cam and you know Merle haggard and all
those motherfuckers, those
guys went hard. Dude, that's a,
that's a whole different kind
of partying and that movie,
that was a good God damn
moves just of the other day.
And I watched it for walk the line.
The hotel I did as far as movies
about like iconic figures,
musical figures. It's one of the best.
So one of the best. I like she Phoenix,
she's fantastic. She's fantastic. And
Joaquin. Phoenix is a bad motherfucker.
It's a great fucking movie, man. Johnny
Cash. It's my dog's named Johnny Cash.
I'm S.
I've always been a huge Johnny Cash
song just because he was so legitimate,
you know, like he was so legit. His
songs were, they just seem right,
you know?
You know what I'm saying?
Like there was like Folsom prison blues
is one of my favorite songs of all time.
You know,
just that.
The idea that this guy is sitting in
the prison looking at these guys come by
and a train, they're probably drinking
coffee and smoking big cigars.
Fuck. He was awesome. What does this
right here, a redemption by Johnny Cash,
Sin and redemption and thank God the
redemption or I wouldn't be here,
which is a title of the last song I wrote.
He's also one of the highway men,
which is one of the great
unheralded songs of our generation.
Have you ever heard that song?
I was a highway man. God Damn,
that's a fucking song. It's
Willie Nelson. Merle haggard,
Johnny Cash altogether. I
think someone else too. Well,
the fuck else was in there.
That's a,
he's got to think. We don't love her
better. Let her know you love her.
I haven't seen it. You know you
love her. I love, I love Kelly.
Kirsten Kelly Carson.
You forgot about that.
They just came to me Kelly cause
yeah, I'm trying to find Johnny Cash.
Waylon Jennings and Kris Kristofferson.
That too. It was a tour that it wasn't
wise. App Dot. Wow. Johnny Cash,
Waylon Jennings and Kris Kristofferson.
Holy Shit.
Kris Kristofferson is bad.
Fuck Aa is all the way up to those
blade movies. He was a bad motherfucker
is all. Dude's got bored and decided.
Tore it again. You know what?
He was good at Bro.
Payback play a little of that wasn't even
pay payback with James Coburn and Mel
Gibson. Yes. Really? He's
the gangster and payback.
Well, he's a good actor on top
of being a great musician. Yeah.
I'm not being facetious about
those blade movies either. I,
I loved those movies man. Especially
the first one. I loved the first one.
The first one was great. First one. I
loved Stephen Dorff, his best moves,
one of his best
performances is the bad guy.
You know who else is good in that Donald
Loke? Everybody's good in that. It's,
that's a fucking great goddamn movie as
far as like vampire comic book movies go.
That was a great one guy. You know,
as they progressed into two and three,
they kind of got even like too funky.
I liked the first one,
but I was a huge fan of that at
that comic book when I was a kid.
Blade was awesome. He had teak knives,
he had knives that are made out of wood.
Teak is like a really hard wood and that's
how he cares. Kill all these vampires.
Yeah,
we'll always teak blades.
It's amazing that when things go
bad for an actor, they always, they,
it pisses me off that they get into comedy
and that pisses me off that they try
it.
Like if it's just another day at the
fucking office and if they only knew that
it's not a another day at the office,
a lot of them try it for a while and they
make it on charisma and stage presence,
dance moves and tops of girl would say
it's a 30 minute thing to be up there an
hour.
It really needs to perfection and the
whole thing and it's just something that
it doesn't. Either way it micro. It just
surprises me that somebody could think.
It's like if I can say,
you know what,
instead of going to the show
to con white belt class,
I'm just going to go to the black belt
class and I'm just going to walk in there
because I could throw a good sidekick.
That's what you're making me feel like
you're not respecting the people around
you it, I don't think they have any idea
what it is. No, they don't. They don't.
They don't. They know, but I
don't think any of us did either.
I don't think we really knew what it
was until we started doing it. Yeah,
but we stuck with it. That's
the difference. They could
too, right? I mean all,
I mean it's hard to make a big
generalization, but they could.
There's guys who have
started out as actors,
got into comedy and actually fell in love
with comedy and liked it better than I
ever have a leak in your thing.
You always call the plumber.
You don't have to do it. Your,
I have a love for plumbing,
but you're not going to
fucking do it yourself or you.
And that's why I don't take offense.
It's just something that really bitch,
really, you're just going
to walk into the dancing.
You got to take over this
motherfucker like GSP.
Well you love comedy and you're also
very competitive and a lot of ways like
your, your idea about a comedy like is
very competitive and the comedy is, uh,
that's,
that's the,
the highest heights and then these people
that want to slide over his actors and
think they're going to disrespect
it. Yeah, no, no. I would never,
ever disrespect somebody like
that. I can't imagine like, oh,
that looks easy to do. I know.
Some way. That's the problem.
It's really weird that now more than ever,
I get emails from people that yeah we,
you know,
death squads and inspire on to do stand
up and they get on stage and that's
great.
But then there's that second journey,
there's that second push that
it really comes from you. Yeah.
A lot of people just don't get it just,
it's just
longterm proposition. There's no way
around it. You can't pretend, you know,
you can't do it for a couple of years
and come up with a few minutes and think
you're a fucking national
headliner cause you're not.
It's a long term proposition and
a lot of it is based on your,
you're going to have a bunch
of different kinds of crowds,
a bunch of different kinds of scenarios
and you're going to have to find your
voice by navigating all
those different waters.
And it's tricky and it's not easy.
It's going to take a long time.
You're going to restructure your act.
You could have shows where bits kill and
then another show we're bit turns the
whole audience off and you can't
figure out what the fuck went wrong.
You got to figure it out. It's not
about having a couple of good shows.
It's about massive consistency
over hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of shows
and figuring out where your voices, that
ain't easy no matter what you're doing.
If you were doing fucking slam poetry
contest, if you were writing books,
if you were saying in songs like
finding your particular voices,
fucking hard man to be genuine,
to be completely unique and genuine and
[inaudible] and completely original,
like to your own thoughts. It's
very hard. Very fucking hard.
Just seems easy because he'd go
downstage and be like, what's up bitches?
What are you doing that you know?
And you start talking shit and people
are laughing. You're like, Cam,
I can talk shit too.
But they don't realize how much work it
took to get you to where you could just
figure out what are the right words to
say, what's the right mindset to be?
And when you're on stage,
what are the right combination?
What's the right way to settle into bits?
What's the right way to lead them
into a story? What's the right way?
What keeps them activated?
What backs him down would picks them up.
It's like if there's a little dance
you're doing when you're up there,
like I watch it, I know what you're doing,
I see it and I've known you forever.
I knew you back when you were having
a real hard time with stand up.
Which to me is fascinating because you're
the only guy that I've ever met that
was having a really hard time with
stand up and then add a nowhere.
Like you hit a switch.
You went from having a hard time with
stand up to being a fucking murderer.
We would,
it was almost like you like you fucking
pass through a doorway or something.
Like within two years of you working
at the store, you just figured it out.
He's figured it out one night and
we were up on stage and we're,
we're in the back rather. And you were
up on stage. We were watching you like,
Damn Joey Diaz just turn a fucking corner.
You just figured out how to be funny.
You figured out who you were up there.
It's really weird when you, uh, you get
into anything. There's always that Jesus,
I'm not improving.
Yeah.
Of calming him showing up and this is
just isn't working and then one day out of
the fucking blue pop pow, it just
starts working and it's really weird.
It was stand up.
You don't want to go to sleep,
you want to go home and
keep writing and writing.
And then I became infatuated from 95 to
like 98 but I had so many other things
going on.
You know what I'm saying?
I had so many fucking things going
on that I couldn't really focus,
focus and then I moved to La and
I had all these distractions.
You have all these stupid distractions
when you first moved to La and you're a
karmic agencies, this, that, this,
that, and then one day you just,
something hits you and it goes,
these mother fuckers don't matter.
Nothing really matters.
I've got to go up there and speak what's
in my heart and you just start going
and little by little, once you find your
voice, you become a savage. That's it.
It's like a, it's like a shark tasting
blood. It's like anything else.
When you get that taste and
you just go after it and,
and you know the comedy store
is the fucking comedy store man.
Once you get in the car mystery. To
me that's like, you know John Job,
that's the comedy store.
That's it's as John Jacques Machado,
it throws up a high level that that's it.
It's a high level,
especially in the two thousands when
we were down there and there was,
there was some intense comedy,
there was growing something
for your countenance already
coming up there and you
coming up there.
It was a really intense time and you
go onstage and you get this weird
confidence and it's this fucking thing.
You just get stronger and stronger in the
more people you go up in front of cars.
Then in the beginning they make it
go up in front of people. You know,
going up in front of Mitzi shore is nerve
wracking and going on after they put
you on after a lot of guys that were
really fun and you're going up in front of
Mitzi shore,
you have no idea what that does to you.
At the six year mark going up.
I cannot describe it.
I've thought about it and I've written
about that experience thousands of times
and nothing was more like I blacked out.
I had a blackout to go in front of Mitzi
shore because I knew it was it for a
guy like me, Mitzi shore
turned me down. You know what?
I was going to go back to boulder,
probably stabbed one of
those motherfuckers without
come out. I would just,
when getting out now I would
have been institutionalized.
There's no turning back from that.
It would have crushed my ego. Her,
her taking me gave me another
five year reprieve in my life.
I knew I got something to do for five
more years before I go to jail for killing
somebody.
Like that's how I felt.
Did you really feel like
you're going to do that?
Cause when I met you I never
got that from, yeah. Yeah.
I was part of the part of the,
the the,
the jumping my comedy was the day
I wrote her the letter and I said,
you can't scan me no more. You want to
take the kid, take the fuck you can't,
what am I going to fucking dirt road
were talking about you called her up one
day and told him I didn't know
who you're talking about. Yeah.
I told her that I didn't,
you know that at the end of the
day and I was being this, you know,
some people really cannot handle the
truth and sometimes you have to tell him
and I had a talk to her and then talk to
her again in 99 when I took that change,
it was around 2000 met me in 97
it took me about three years,
but one day in [inaudible]
99 before I went to bed,
I was clean for a couple of days,
maybe three days,
and I went to bed early and I had my,
which to me and I said,
I'm not going to fuck with this no more.
It was one of these things that I
was going into the lion's mouth.
I had a walk on a fine line
with her because I wanted
to be a part of that kid's
life,
but it wasn't looking that way and I was
going to take her shit no more than one
morning I got up room and I went and got
a calling card and I call that mother
fucker and I just laid it out to her
and I told her the opening line was,
I'll never forget this, that listen
between you and I and she knew me. I said,
you know, if you want to
find I would not pass on you.
We contact I'm having with
you is because of this child.
So I pay for a separate phone in her
room and I don't have to talk to you no
more.
Cause she wanted what was killing me at
that time when she wanted to take and
change the child's name.
And my position was when my father died,
my mom remarried, my poor dad that
died, I had to keep his fucking name.
That was just something in my heart.
So I always felt that that's let her
become 18 I'd have to decide what the fuck
she wants to write. That was eating
away whammy when they add no value.
A name didn't have a value to me and this
whole situation didn't have a valid to
me. Once I analyzed it and said, fuck
this bitch and what she stands for,
I turned that corner because
I dropped luggage off.
There's nothing sometimes in comedy,
sometimes in life you're just
carrying around some luggage, man,
that doesn't let you move. The box is
five feet, but the door is only three.
Sorry motherfucker.
And you've got to drop that shit
until you dropped that fucking box.
You ain't going to go
through that door too.
People get locked into
those relationships,
whether they're friendships,
friendships with former ex,
you know, ex wife and husband,
whatever you want to call
that relationship, exes.
But they're like two deer with their
fucking horns locked together and they
can't separate and they fucking,
every day is a push poll.
They fuck with each other
on purpose. You know, I've,
I've known people that went through
horrible divorces where, you know,
you could tell that like they would,
they would like be setting up each
other like, you know, fuck him,
make him pay more, you know, uh, let's,
let's agree to one thing and
then change the terms. Just keep,
keep the bills coming in and like,
I've heard people talk like that.
So it's a horror show.
It's crazy and it's scary.
And this is, this was
the bad end of it, Joe,
that this is the already at the job
in boulder that paid the most educated
schmuck like me.
I was working for a sports adviser and
that you can make anywhere from 20 to
60,000 to football seasons,
six months.
You can make some calves
and that's insane.
There was some guys that make
a hundred grand. There was,
I had a month in December, I made
25 grand work in the fucking phones.
You just got to get some fish. Tibetans
send you money, believe that your is,
you're going to take them through
the fucking bowl season. Listen Bro,
you want to make 50 it's going to cost
you 20 go to Western Union seminar 20,000
and we'll talk about sending them.
Basically buying your knowledge,
your knowledge, but you're buying your
bullshit. It's bad Karma also. Really,
this is what I was doing, so I knew this.
I knew this. All right. I come to La,
Mitzi shore it on past me.
Maybe the Improv pass has been,
but my dream was Mitzi shore.
Who the fuck are you kidding?
My whole thing was the store from day
one people told me to go to the fucking
store. That's your house. That was
my fate. If she turned me down,
I would have probably gone
back to Colorado. Probably
gotten to work over there.
You were there. You'd done sets
in Seattle. You were doing,
when I couldn't go back to go to Seattle,
I would've gone back to Colorado and tried
to be a dad and one day ago I know me
one fucking day. The car breaks
down, there's snow and out.
You get one of those bills and
overdue bill and that's it.
You bump into this fucking book and it
gives you that attitude with his flip
flops on. I was going to
run over this motherfucking,
I was gonna do 50 fucking years.
So you know what, as much as I,
the comedy store has that much power in
my life. Came along at the right time,
came along at the right time.
Do you think that people create that?
I mean that's like the big,
uh, the big hippy, new age, uh,
argument about lives that you create
these possibilities in life, that you're,
you're responsible for all these
different events that are happening too.
They're not random events.
These are events that are sort of
created by your own intentions. Yes.
Do you feel that sometimes,
absolutely.
One thing I learned was that
until you take responsibility,
you ain't gonna move forward. Cause
motherfuckers that get off the stage, Bro,
the audio sucks the sound.
I watched a guy eat the pipe
quite fucking bombed. Yeah. And
that's it. And then everything else.
And until you come through that,
you can't really,
and that was big for me that I believe
that they listened. I go to bed now,
I go home, I put my feet up, I watch
the news and I go to bed like nothing.
You know, 20 years ago I
didn't go to bed like nothing.
I had to shut my window a certain
way and close my door, shut away,
and I couldn't leave the light on at night
because I owed money to a drug dealer
like rob somebody. I created
all those scenarios. I didn't,
I didn't make that kidnapping up.
I went there with a gun.
I knew what I was doing,
but it's funny how quick the turnaround
was between like 99 you know,
like it's,
it all just sort of stopped.
It all stopped loving and they kept
stopping. You know, it kept stopping.
What you're telling me is that I
never did blog at after 2006 that's,
you're trying to tell me who me.
That's you're trying to tell me why.
I wouldn't say that.
I'm just saying
that's the weirdest way to phrase that
sentence. I haven't done Boston one day.
One day, one day I went home with
a check. So one day I went home.
I just stopped doing book. That's what
you're trying to never done that again,
number one. So what I'm saying? I'm saying
about being a criminal. No, no, no, no.
I'm busting your balls. I can't
believe what I'm fucking telling you.
That's night. 2006 one
day I went home. Brian,
one day I went home and just stopped
doing cocaine though. Rehab, no hug.
I didn't call nobody.
I didn't piss my ear.
I didn't give my life to Allah was no all
big game. There was none of that shit.
Okay. Whatever the fuck that shit is,
he never go with nothing. Uber Game.
So my point is that what
happened was I dropped,
I kept dropping the pain that I had at
that luggage that I had. I forced it out.
I just didn't fucking stop doing drugs.
I overcame whatever was making
me do those fucking drugs.
Society wasn't making me do drugs.
Obamacare. How funny is that?
They found heroin in the Bronx
with Obamacare envelope. Austin,
Boston man hysteric instead Obamacare on,
it was on heroin,
Obamacare,
everything.
In a lot of ways it's random
things that happen as well, right?
Because I broke this sometimes.
Yeah.
People wake up on the wrong
side of the fucking bed.
They come at you and you understand
your fucking ground and you got to stay.
No Bitch. And people get their
feelings hurt. Yes. But no,
I created a lot of shit that happened
in my life. There's no fucking way.
You also have to stop silliness or it'll
invade your life and ruin your quality
of life.
Like if you don't get upset at people,
sometimes there's times where people are
infringing on your happiness with your
bullshit bullshit. And
you're like, listen man,
you need to learn your
own for your own good.
You need to learn that what you're doing,
it's like socially unacceptable. You're,
you're passing it off on other people.
You're passing off this shitty reality
that you're trying to promote something
you, you can get locked in a person
like that, as we were saying before,
with like bad relationships.
And then all of a sudden,
like every day you're dealing with this
person's nonsense distortions and lies
and it can never trust. Like who was it
your fault. No, it's never your fault.
Right. And it's never your fault.
It's always somebody else's fault.
And when you deal with people like that
on a regular basis and you communicate
with people like that,
it makes it incredibly difficult for
you to live your life because you're
constantly,
you're constantly like debating
or dismissing bullshit.
Like is this bullshit?
It might people shit.
And then somewhere along the line
you realize, well, fuck this man,
I got to stop hanging out
with this person. This
person's an asshole. You know,
that person doesn't give a fuck about the
truth. They don't give a fuck about me.
They just,
and I've had a few of those in my life
and you just cut them loose and when you
cut them loose, like you're a
way better person, you're like,
your life is free and
easy. And I'm like, oh,
it's not that I'm like
constantly engaged in conflict.
It's that if you surround yourself
with the wrong kind of people,
you will be constantly
engaged in conflict.
Whether you want it or whether you
have that intention or not. Like,
it's not just about having
the right intentions,
you gotta make the right choices
as to who you put in your world.
Because if you put a bunch of shitheads
that don't care about evolving,
they don't care about getting it together
and all they're trying to do is pass
off a nonsense on you.
Oh you gotta fucking,
you got a Shitty road.
You've got a shitty road ahead of you.
You know I used to love guns.
I wasn't a gun up like your buddy,
but I loved guns. I love
having them. I loved them.
And the same thing one day I was like,
every time I carry a gun that's a,
let's put that out there almost right?
It's like a magnet for other guns and
you're not the only one that says that.
It's like a magnet. I'm telling
you, when I carried a gun,
I carry the Gulf for a very short
time because I didn't like it.
I didn't see the purpose for it.
It's a nice thing to use
to try to be a tough guy,
but all it's going to do is
get you in fucking trouble.
Cause you pull that motherfucker out
wanting motherfuckers going to pull that
money. You got real tough guys. And I
knew that going in. I fucking knew it.
I wanted to fire it at somebody.
But I tell you what man,
it was amazing how he used
to go home at night and go,
what the fuck just happened tonight?
Why did I have to go from my
reach from like Gunther it,
why would it six other people in the
room and a coke party with guns because
guns attract.
They're like fucking magnets.
And one day I got rid of all those guns.
It was like I lost 18 fucking pounds
of drama. The same thing 10 years ago,
this phone would be ringing with people
that were asking me questions about,
you know, how do you
get roadwork? You know,
why don't you take me on the fucking road.
You know you can all these fucking people
calling you with these questions and
then at the same time they have low
concern for you. They really don't.
They're just trying to pull you down.
Especially in this fucking town.
If you let people pull you down,
but I don't know what you're doing.
It's not happening for me. What do
you want? What do you want me to do?
You got like right and get on stage every
fucking night. What'd you do? Ask me. Oh,
I went to my sister's wedding.
Well go fuck your mother.
Then go to the fucking wedding.
You were one of the last guys
that picking that out too.
It Burns my fucking core that people
come up to you and put their lack of
Vietnam.
I saw somebody,
but I started calling me with
at the store 13 years ago.
I was going to screen some stupid
movie that my buddy was in.
My wife was sleeping.
So let me go down there and as I
was walking around the corner, her,
Joey and I went up and I go,
I didn't even know who was.
And he was telling me what he was doing
in front of their house. He was working,
you hear about this?
And he was telling me,
you know what he was doing
there and what he was,
he was working and I drove back to
fucking studio city with like tears in my
eyes because he had every
opportunity that I had.
He was a good look and knew when they
moved to this fucking town. But to him,
he used to go to the store and drink
and everything was how e and now I'm
supposed to feel guilty on the fucking
one-on-one cause this fucking schmucks
got a job working until fucking two in
the morning parking cars or something,
you know? I mean, we all had
the same opportunities here.
Well there's people that feel like those
people in your life to teach you that
lesson.
To see people fail and have regrets and
see people not give 100% or not give it
all their focus or give it all
their honesty, you know, give it,
give it who the fuck you really are.
We see those people and that regret is
almost there to let us know like don't
ever let that happen again.
As I was getting in my car,
he made a comment and he was one of
those guys always had to have that one
comment that the store,
they may like a fucking comment.
I just want to say
something about something.
It must've been nice doing blow all
those years, like something just,
you know what I'm saying? Like he's one
of those guys that he's put you down,
right. He had a, and I just got
in the car, like I said, you know,
this is why that guy's
parking cars and you know,
I'm on the fucking road work and
at least try to make things happen.
This is why this guy is barking.
Fucking,
there was a guy that I want
to mention his name but you a,
you'd warned me about him a long time ago,
long before it ever went real bad form.
And then one time I was back in the east
coast and the guy hadn't done comedy
and he fucking a couple of years and he's
like trying to get ahold of me to open
up for me. Like what? You just,
you just got to get back on stage after
a couple of years and open up at the big
show. Like really? That's
where you're going to do? Oh,
you had your fucking mind.
Like what kind of weird request is that
you haven't done comedy in two years.
You, you want to go up and a in front
of a sold out club. Like that's,
that's ridiculous.
Like why would you think that you
could just do that like you get,
but that's what they,
there's a lot of guys that didn't make
any comedy that felt like they didn't
make it because nobody helped him.
And I've heard that so many times I've
heard that stupid argument like I wasn't
in with the right group or if
you're not in with the right group,
it's very hard to get roadwork
like what are you talking about?
What do you all you have to do is be
funny. If you're funny, people find you.
It's one of the easiest businesses of all
time. You get proven onstage for sure.
Easiest to understand. This is how
easy it works. You go on stage,
you get the people to laugh,
people notice. Then they
started offering your work.
It's that simple.
When you prove that you have a certain
amount of time and you prove that you can
consistently perform really well.
People want to give you some
mark that give you a little here.
They give you a little there. You make
some connections, you start networking.
The next thing you know you started,
you know moving in your area a little bit,
getting a few gigs here and there and
it takes fucking years and you've got to
keep doing it. If you don't keep doing
it, then you really didn't want to do it.
But if you do keep doing it,
you get to a point where you're Joey
Diaz and if you're one of those guys that
didn't really want to do it and one day
you see Joey Diaz and he said it moves
been good foot. Duke cuckold
Hoosiers. Hmm, you're there.
You're like a living lesson.
Like that guy's like a little,
a little stop on your journey.
Well, it's a book. I broke my on
the drive home. I was like, wow.
And when I had the same opportunities,
we both walked into that store.
He used to get spots. He was
good. He was decent. Yeah,
showed potential whatever,
nine o'clock spots,
couple belly room spots and now you're
out here with fucking the 11 o'clock at
night and you know like wow,
that's,
that's with everything Joey. That's
with music. That's with writing.
That's with anything where it's up to
you to create what you put out there.
It's a lot of people fucking false.
What's Bill Hicks? His friends not
think of the guy from Portland,
Oregon that he was started at Houston
width and they both will pour on them.
Let me talking about comic. Yeah, he
was important. He's from Houston, Texas.
Also guy with all the tattoos all
over her. I don't know. He uh,
they did comedy at some place in Houston.
Not Jimmy Pineapple. No, no, no, no, no.
To kind of, what was a funny
Tennyson, this kid is, is still alive
and he's still on the road. Yeah.
Yeah. Jimmy Pineapple still. He didn't,
this guy is in Portland,
Oregon.
I'm not sure. I didn't hear
anything. Dale Dame. Uh,
I think he's even managed by somebody in
La cause he was doing some gigs at the
Improv.
I saw he wrote something 25 years
ago about his after bill died,
about his relationship with bill,
how bill moved to La and he got
married and build it the tonight show.
I had a kid and bill did HBO.
I had another kid and bill was on tour
and while we still remained friends,
it was a beautiful and he goes,
I never had jealousy for him.
All I wanted was the best because I knew
that he used the one that they used to
do comedy at the pizza
place with in Houston,
Texas early on pizza place.
They should do.
Yeah, I know who you're talking about,
but I don't know who you're talking about.
Mac, Lindsey. There was a no, no, no.
There was a bunch of those guys from that.
Why would you even say Mac Lindsey?
Because I thought that,
I mean he used to hang out with that.
Lindsay was so much
younger than those guys.
More than 15 years younger
than those guys. Easily.
Maybe even 20 white slate slate. That's
it. To white slave boy. It's lit.
Also went up to Portland.
Uh,
yeah, those guys, those comedy outlaws.
What's fascinating about all those guys
was how much they were so obviously
influenced by Kennison.
Those guys got in a world,
I mean they were very talented guys.
I worked at Jimmy, Jimmy Pineapple,
one of the first times they ever
came to Houston at the last stop.
Very funny guy. But they were
all real good, real solid comics.
But they were so obviously caught up in
the the wave of this one wild fucking
maniac.
Even when I first saw Hicks,
Hicks had like all these
Kinison mannerisms,
like he probably didn't even realize it.
He was like so used to being around
Kennison and Kennison just being the man
like 86 86 Kennison was like
for people today cannot explode.
They can't really understand what kind
of an impact that guy had on the world of
standup comedy. He threw the whole
fucking bored in the air. The whole,
the whole thing was changed by one guy,
this big fat guy screaming about pain.
Nobody had ever done that before.
It was a completely new thing and the
jokes were crisp and they were solid and
he got to the end. They had really good
points like about the kid in Africa,
you know about being married.
I wasn't making,
you know like about going to hell
like hell would be like club med.
Get Devil goes well he'd been married.
Wow, this is fucking old hat for you.
Come on, I'll show you around. This is
where we tortured souls when he would,
when he would talk about like
his life and his payment,
it gets fucking red in
the face and scream out.
There was nothing like that, nothing
like that at the time. And so these guys,
they're all the, all these
outlaws, the comedy outlaws,
they all got swept up in
the wake of this mad genius,
a mad genius with a head injury.
You know, his story is fucking book.
His book is Great. His brother wrote a
book called, uh, my brother Sam. Sam.
It's a great fucking book. If you're a
standup comic, you, I'll give it to you.
I find that I get it for you on Amazon.
See if we can find it on Amazon.
I'm sure there's probably some
used copies that are available.
It's a great fucking book.
I read that and Seattle in 95,
one of the most important
parts of stories. How can,
it seems like a regular kid,
normal, shy and regular kid
gets hit by a fucking car.
He get hurt, like really
bad, like bad head injury.
And then he comes out of that
just a wild motherfucker,
which is wild and reckless
and confident and crazy.
Like literally he got head injuries into
being the greatest comic of all time
because he went from there like right
into like he was doing all that invent
gelical preaching and he took that
energy and wrote it right in to stand up.
And a lot of it came about. Most
likely if you listened to his brother,
who knows better than anybody.
It's the personality changes
because of a head injury
that's fucking crazy. His brother was
crazy effort. They were all crazy.
Just brothers. Carla bowl was
crazy. All those dudes were crazy.
Call the Bose still out there banging
and banging it, hitting the clubs.
The clubs still loves it. You
know? Look, even, you know,
somebody tried to explain this to me
once a long time ago about standup comedy
and he was like,
look man,
even if you just earn
enough to make a living,
he earned the live in talent jokes,
jokes. Oh, it's like everywhere you go,
you're making people laugh.
You're having a good time.
They're enjoying themselves and you feed
yourself that way. That's fantastic.
He goes,
if you can do that to the day you die,
do it because it's the best way to live.
And I was,
I remember like that totally makes sense.
Like even if you're just a guy who
never really makes it but can kind of
headline enough to bring a good
crowd, you know, and half, you know,
half filled clubs all across the
country, you're going to get by. Well you
made it, especially now with see these
and tee shirts and hats and Yoyos.
You don't have the opportunity
now, Twitter and Twitter, youtube,
even a low income, it
could make, you know,
so it guy that's not working
the Improv per se. Okay.
Let's say a guy that doesn't work
the Improv's with a funny bones.
There's a thousand clubs,
there's still a lot of cloud of clothes,
a lot of clubs at Ohio U,
you know,
Husky and then there's like
the Austin Room and all those.
But then there's an underbelly to that.
They're going to open up another
room in Tempe but listen to them.
Yeah. And the spring. So that's who's
going to open it. The people who won't,
Rick Bronson's Comedy Club in
Minneapolis in the old east orange. Wow.
Uh, Easter. Other for that one at
Tempe. So you have stand up live,
you have the Tempe Improv,
you have standup Scottsdale and you
have the other one in Scottsdale.
That's for holy shovel one night.
And you have this place coming in.
[inaudible] six rooms in
the Arizona area outlined,
well it's always been like a very comedy
town.
You know,
people that like to have fun and there's
not a lot of options in the Tempe
Improv is one of the best options
in the area for the longest time.
So you've got like a whole community
that's been sort of raised on really good
combat. Like that's always been
an option. If you live in Tempe,
that Improv is a big stop for a
lot of guys. So like every week,
you know you're going to get this guy
who's a national headlight or Brian cow
and Joey d if you're going to get that
kind of comedy like almost every weekend.
So they they,
they really built up a big audience
that I bet they can't even satisfy
Tempe
called Dick Suckers are us.
They got some Dick Sucking motherfucker.
It's though they'll suck your dick wet
or dry coked up just with a shot at
Aspen.
They will suck that pipe anywhere.
There are some nasty cocksuckers down
there. There's an organism I think pissed.
Tell. Tell Brian about,
take your time. Hurry up.
It's amazing how down there is where the
fucking women who love sucking cock for
like one day they'd go, fuck it.
Let's move to Arizona then this,
everybody that result is hot and they
suck Dick. Fuck it. And they really do.
It's really a weird place. I
cannot believe it anymore, but
what are you going to do?
You know what I'm saying?
What the fuck am I talking about?
I have no idea.
Is Anybody fucking though your movie
comes out this week because this week and
you got to actually go to New York
and watch it. Did you enjoy it?
Was it fun because this is your first
time seeing it, edit it. I guess too.
I taught two times last week. Yeah, but
you liked it that much though. I saw it.
I had no choice.
You know what I'm saying?
I it go with my wife and I went one
night in New York. He likes seeing,
you also met the guy that plays big
pussy. Yes. And on the Sopranos,
you know, ever since I've known
you ever since I've known you,
you get confused with this guy,
you know and you eat and you usually
don't even tell people. You're like,
all right, get over here.
And they're like, I love you.
You know? I was like, yeah,
whatever. Get out of here. You know?
I tried to tell him like sometimes
I ask people and they're like,
they'll stop me in the
UFC of those though.
Why are you the best? Was The lady
who was asking me who I was like, oh,
so you stopped me to take a picture.
You don't know who the fuck I am.
Fucking barrel cooler.
Cocksuckers
okay. And you said that he also
gets confused with you sometimes.
At least that that day he did it.
It was nice.
It was really nice to finally meet him.
He gave me a big hug and oh
his stat. Where did you do that? At the
premiere of the movie. So we being art,
we were walking. He kind of, he looks at
me and he comes right over and he's like,
man, what the fuck? He goes,
I was just the bathroom.
People asking me how much fun
was it shoot with the there.
And I kept telling him it wasn't made
and here you are. So he was very nice.
He was very nice to talk to.
You know they're using you in the clip
of you seen the trailer for smaller tray.
All of them. They're using that
one line. It's like bad Baywatch.
The power of the Internet though.
That's the strength of the Joe Rogan
experience and the power of the motherfuck
tell that story because that
story is fucking hilarious story.
It's a crazy story.
Like they had no idea who you were.
They booked you because
they thought you were funny.
You go to the premiere and when your
face is on the premiere. No, no, no, no.
They shot the movie cause it
director referred me, right. He goes,
Joe was a hard shot. So they put me in
the movie, but then they take the movie,
they show it in the Midwest and all these
places to see how it scores and where
they showed it. They don't show
no titles, no names, no nothing.
And they give you a questionnaire
and one of the guys.
So when I was shooting a movie,
everybody was very nice,
but nobody really talked to me.
Everybody had their Starbucks cup and
nobody asked me if I wanted Starbucks.
You know what I'm saying though,
nobody asked me if I wanted to Starbucks,
which I wouldn't have drank coffee,
but Jesus Christ asked me.
But I was just a fucking regular guy.
When they screened the films,
I guess people started yelling, no
blue cheese, go fuck your mother. I go,
what the fuck is going on? And all of
these reports came back. So they got it.
So when I went to do the Adr, they will
all, they're like, come in, you know,
every hill comes out of jail.
You broke it.
Cherry weird.
They didn't know who you were.
They didn't know that, you know,
this is big what we do here.
That's why it's a fucking movement.
They didn't know that.
So once they find out they started liking
my cigarettes and shit and rubbing my
shoulders. Well if you think about
what a a television show get,
like the amount of people
that watch a television show,
like have a television shows on
every week. How many people watch it?
What's a big one? A big ones.
Like you know, like, like
what does duck dynasty get?
It's the height. The
biggest ratings ever. Yeah.
They crushed us when we were
up against them on Scifi.
It's like 14 million cable.
It's not like the highest rate Keto
that you will get more hits than fucking
come out that show on Fx. I know
that you guys were killing that show.
We did very well on [inaudible].
Didn't have to come come up.
The Joe Rogan podcast was getting more
downloads than that come l bell on Fx.
Did you know that you
will get more downloads?
There's people watching that shit that
spike put on with Randy and everybody.
No disrespect.
You know,
I love them in May that that
show they had on for a while.
You're talking about downloads, you're
talking about ratings, downloads,
podcast viewers.
How many people would download and
watching this or listening to a show,
the show that fucking come out had on Fx,
but you're not,
you're not talking about the Scifi show.
You're talking about pod.
Got The side of the fight strong.
I'm talking about that more people watch
this to not show more people watch this
then that fucking series they had before.
Glory on spike. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
You follow what I'm saying? More
people. It's amazing how many viewers,
how many people watch.
It's amazing how many places I go now
that people hear the voice of God and show
it is. I just heard you on the podcast
the other day, man. It's amazing.
And the people that will say that.
Do you realize it or does it,
is it one thing is it,
did it creep up on you and it like takes
you time to go holy shit. Like this is,
this is actually getting kind of nutty.
Like when did you realize it?
When did you, when did you realize
like the impact of doing stuff online?
Year and a half ago,
I really felt the Urbino
security people talking to me and they
say people, Tsa people talking to me.
You know, Tsa people talk to
me now. Amen. How you doing?
That was funny last time and you're right,
what you said about the Mars program,
whatever, how many people
will say shit to me? You know,
this is huge.
This little movement is fucking huge.
Where we're closing in on 8 million
downloads a month and that doesn't include
stitcher and that doesn't
show you to reuse stream.
Such a million crazy show close to.
It's seven 50 and then whatever it is,
it's a lot. It's a lot of individuals.
That is, I don't know. That's a lot.
That's a fucking lot. It's
definitely not 8 million. I mean,
I don't know how many admit it is.
There's a lot of different
people downloading it.
Definitely killing half
the TV shows on television.
If they go by anybody's killing anything,
you know, it's just a different thing.
It's just they didn't have it before.
Before people were stuck,
they were stuck with radio
or they'd have to, you know,
bring a cassette or you know, they
listen to books on tape. That was like,
you're only good option, but now they
can do whatever the fuck they want.
There's so much shit you get download,
you listen to your podcast.
This isn't a Dunkin's.
You could download a a Dan Carlin
podcasts and learn about some history.
You could download us, you know,
science podcasts he get, I mean,
there's the numbers of podcasts now or
just fucking staggering the options that
a person has. That's why I keep telling
people, you can't charge money for this.
Like if you think you're going
to get away with charging money,
you're going to make a little bit
money from the people you charge,
but you're ultimately going to fuck
yourself because it's going to slow your
growth down.
Your,
your growth is best achieved if you
follow the spirit of the Internet.
Spirit of the Internet is give people
freak shit, give people free shit.
That's good. And that way when you
develop a relationship with them,
you develop a relationship where you've
already given them something like,
you know, like you're not just constantly
asking them to buy your tickets,
constantly asking them to do this.
It's a like a really easy free thing and
you're happy that they enjoy it and you
do it in a spirit of that.
Not even in the spirit of
trying to make money off of it.
And then it's all sorts
of falls into place.
And that's what's happened with
all of us up at four 45 of them.
You're ridiculous. You do it in the
weirdest way. I fucking love it.
You just hurt Brian's feelings.
I usually watch the first half.
I had a Texas motherfucker twice at noon.
Tell him that the podcast is it too,
like,
oh,
I could wake up with a pair of underwear
across his face trying to find this
mother fucker. Molly Dodd who said
every night, yeah, he's going to die.
I'm not going to make it.
When I get up, listen to this.
Some nights I go to bed or they like,
when I come back on a Sunday,
I'm dead five shows all weekend,
you know, five hours a night.
I fucking go to bed at fucking six this
sudden nights I get up at three and I'm
looking at your Instagram,
so you're going to fucking pink dot.
You're going to the other place.
You'd take pictures of pancakes.
You're living like we were living.
You were living like essentially like we
were living in the 90s yeah, it's, it's,
it's a life of a comic. It's
the life of a comic. You know,
you're going to bed as I'm getting up,
you and Ari. Ari is fucking up all hours.
He's a full savage.
I looked at his Instagram the other day.
I have photos of all the
spots he's doing in town.
This is mother fuckers don't like five,
six bucks at night going all
around New York from like eight,
8:00 PM on, you know, he's got spots.
All he's at 1:00 AM spots at Caroline's
and shit. He just going up. But he's,
he's getting excited by it.
Speaking of exciting this weekend,
ladies and gentlemen at the Mirage,
the greatest line up ever been
to put together ever. Joey Diaz,
Brian Cowen and Ari Shaffir,
God damn.
And me and uh, at the Mirage. Yeah. I
mean, yeah. I don't even need to be there.
So this show that's so fucking good.
I can just just bring everybody up and
say goodnight. It'd be fucking beautiful.
Yeah. My, I might just take the, no,
I'm going to tell some jokes, but look,
you can't, can't get a better lamp. No,
we've never done a crazier show them that.
That's the craziest show I've
ever done for headliners.
Everybody having a good time. It'll be
sold out. It's almost sold out already.
And it's at the Mirage at
the Terry Fator. Uh, he,
I guess he has his own theater there.
I've never seen it before,
but it's supposed to be a
sweet, sweet room. We're gonna
have a good fucking time.
Joe. Just a room was in the fucking head.
What's going on with the fight? This,
I want you to go there man, but you're not
going to be there. I know. No one knows.
You know. Look, it's this, it's a
crazy fight. Anderson Silva all time,
greatest mixed martial artists
that's ever lived. I mean,
he's got stellar his entire career
dominating champions strangling Dan
Henderson, knocking out veto over
the fucking front kick to the face,
the greatest martial artists that's
ever walked the face here is a guy lives
like he's in a fucking movie
and he gets clipped. Boom,
he gets hurt and a dude plays basketball
with his head. Boom, boom, boom.
And he's out and he, and he, you
know, referee has to rescue him.
And it all came about in large
part due to him clowning. Well,
what people don't realize is there was a
moment in that first round where he had
Anderson Silva really hurt and it was
not when he was going for the heel hook,
it was um,
he was ground and pounding Anderson and
he blasted him on the Chin and you see
Anderson's head bounce off the
ground. He realized like, Whoa,
that is a fucking hard shot. And
he got clipped with, he got hurt,
his eyes roll up and roll back.
He got really rocked.
And I think that severely influenced
his decision to try to up the antics and
really drag Weidman into a standup banner,
which he thought he
would have the advantage.
But I think one of the reasons why he
got clipped with that left hook and all
that clown and around was because
he got fucking hurt on the ground.
And I think he really didn't want to go
there. He almost got his leg ripped off.
He got out of the leg lock and
who knows if his knee popped,
he could have easily popped his
knee in that exchange was quite a,
a deep leg lock.
And then he goes from there and you know,
he's trying to go to into a
standup war and he's like,
come on, stand up, stand up.
You know?
And then he's kicking him and taunting
him and pretending that he's hurt and
drunk.
But Weidman is just a motherfucker dude.
And he clips him and knocks him out.
So the question comes when you're
coming into this fight, it's like, wow.
Much different would the result have
been if Anderson just treated it like a
fucking Samurai,
if he went in there with no antics and
just laser beam precision striking chops,
those legs up eventually lands a big head
kick or something, you know, who knows?
Who knows what would happen? We'll
see this weekend while we won't even,
because he didn't do it then.
So who is he now and who is Weidman now?
You know, the first fight is going to be
one of the most mysterious fights ever.
It's going to be one of the most hotly
debated fights ever because everyone's
always going to say, what
would have happened if
Anderson wasn't fucking around?
What would have happened if Anderson
took that dude super serious and just
stayed super disciplined in the feet
and was able to just like in the sun and
fight to get taken down the first round,
but then keep the fight standing for
the rest of the fight and then put them
away. Who knows? We won't
know. We don't know anymore,
but we do know is that Chris Weidman
knocked Anderson silver the fuck out and
that's shocking.
He's the greatest fighter of all time
and Weidman clipped him with a fucking
long left hook but bank right on the chin
dropped him and then finished him off
and he's going to be so
confident coming into this fight.
It was just going to be a
really interesting fight
because I think Anderson is
going to be real confident cause Anderson
knows that if he minds his p's and q's
and keeps the fight standing,
he should have a pretty distinct advantage
as long as he doesn't do anything
silly like the last time and then
to Weidman is already beat him.
Weidman's already knocked him out.
Weidman's gotten better.
Weidman still young Weidman just had
that Regena keen shit done on his knees.
He went to Germany for a week to get
his knees treated and apparently he's,
he's got his whole workout.
Like everything he does,
you could do it online.
Everything he does, he like, he, he, he,
he puts it online so people can watch,
puts up his diet, puts up his workout
schedule, tells Anderson when it's,
his strategy is, it
doesn't give a fuck. Sadly,
it's not gonna it's not gonna matter.
I'm going to get them.
It's a fascinating fight.
It's fucking fascinating.
I don't know what's going to happen,
man.
I have no idea if Anderson went out
and knocked him out. I mean, yeah,
that's a possibility. If Weidman
took them down and submitted them,
that's a possibility. Weidman knocked
him out. That's a possibility.
What of Anderson Takes Weidman's back
and submits him? Who the fuck knows? Man?
That'd be a good, that's a wild fight.
And it's for legacy too. For Anderson.
This is for legacy.
You know,
Anderson suffered like that's
a humiliating defeat and
especially when he knows
that there's a lot of people that
blame it on his clowning, you know,
that's like an for Brazil like Brazil got.
There was a lot of times where
he went to Brazil where you know,
people were like disappointed he was
their champion, not just the champion,
but the greatest champion and he came
from their country. There's a lot of,
and he feels that disappointment and he
wants to make them happy and this fight,
I think this is going to be very
intense. I'm fucking pumped. God. Yes.
I wish you would give them the card Josh.
Josh Barnett against.
That's a good fight though,
against Travis Travis Hoppa Brown.
Lots of very good Rhonda and
Rhonda Rousey. Miesha Tate,
Josh Barnett and Travis
Browne is a dangerous fight.
That's a tricky fight for both guys.
King Kong that Travis Brown might be one
of the toughest motherfuckers thought
he's a big boy. He's six,
seven. Travis Brown. I would
say he's, if I had to guess,
I would say he's at least six, five, six,
six, six, five, somewhere around there.
He's a big boy, but he's also, he moves
good man. He moves light on its feet,
striking Mr motherfucking Overeem's
front kick to the face dude.
And that was after taking a far
road eating in that first round,
he took a beating that would have stopped
99.999% of the people on the planet if
they were in that position
taking those kinds of shots.
Alastar was murdering him with knees
and there's nobody throws needs like
Alister have you never seen
Alistair Overeem fight?
Alistair Overeem was the k one Grand
Prix champion and he's a super high level
kickboxer for MMA.
Like one of the most high level guys
to ever fight in MMA in the heavyweight
division,
especially in that mother fucker delivers
knees and a totally different way.
It's all just hip and technique
and torque and a lump.
I mean those fucking knees
go deep into your soul.
They pass through your skin and push your
fucking belly right into your backbone.
Like they make your body go numb because
he's literally smashing his knee all
the way into your nerves.
I mean,
they're ruthless knees and
his whole body gives out.
He goes down and he's just getting
fucking pound it and you thinking they're
going to stop this fight any second now.
And he figures out a way to get up and,
and, and then Allister gets tired and
then he gets up and Alistair is clearly
exhausted because he's triangle
head kicks. Right. He kept
throwing. Uh Huh. Right.
I been that truck and he landed that
one straight up the middle right to the
chin and Alistair's legs give
out and Travis finishes him off.
It's one of the greatest comebacks. Was
I to fight? It was supposed to be, uh,
I don't know, but via got hurt. I
don't know if he scheduled. Who's, uh,
let me find out right now. Mia
got hurt. Somebody got hurt.
Yeah. I wonder. I wonder
who he is supposed to be
fighting next. I don't know.
I don't know. Let me find that out.
I'll find that out. Next fight.
He's a guy that, uh, a lot of
people thought he was going to,
especially after the Brock Lesnar fight,
a lot of people thought that he was
going to be the fucking man. Oh,
he's fighting Frank Mir. He's
supposed to hard cheeses. UFC One 69,
which is the super bowl. Yeah, that's
right. Wow, that's crazy fight man.
Both guys got a lot to lose. Was on the
super bowl card. It's a good question.
I think it's Hanan Barao and
Dominick Cruz is the main event
that's a, that's a, that's going to
be a big fight for the east coast.
And still to this day,
it can't be legal in New York.
It's fucking crazy.
It's one of the, the
weirdest as far as like, uh,
examples of how corruption shapes what
people are allowed to enjoy and not a
joy.
It's a,
they figured out a way to
keep the UFC Adam, New York,
despite a giant hit to the
economy. I mean, they take money.
They're taking money away from New York
by not letting it come to New York.
It would,
it would bring hundreds of millions of
dollars in revenue to restaurants and
local bars. And I mean, the,
the impact would be huge.
The Prestige would be huge. People would
love to see it and they still, they have,
it's not like they don't
have combat sports.
They have boxing regularly in New York.
They have kickboxing,
they've had glory in New York.
They had glory high, you know,
high level kickboxing and Madison
Square Garden. It's amazing.
These motherfuckers,
they're there,
they're figuring out a way to keep
people from enjoying what they want.
But you know what, man, there's
always going to be that.
This is always going to be,
that there's always going to be people
that are trying to make money off of
something. If for folks who don't
even know what it's all about,
the culinary union keeps the UFC out of
New York and they know that it's a big
event for New York. Um,
but they want the UFC.
UFC is owned by Zoomba and zoo for
also own station casinos, same guys.
And they want them to go union
to Culinary Union wants those,
those hotels to go union. So they're
taking all their dues and they're,
they're battling the UFC hardcore.
They develop these like crazy websites.
They contact gay and lesbian groups.
They do everything they can to try to
like make a big force against the UFC.
The crazy thing is they contact gay and
lesbian groups, but the UFC is like they,
they're openly in support
of gay and lesbian rights.
They actually donate money to the various
centers and the UFC is like totally
open minded firefighters. Fighters
had been reprimanded for you know,
calling people gay slurs and things along
those lines. Then they're not, you know,
the culinary union is just trying
to figure out a way to get the UFC.
It's amazing because if they did it, but
if they did, if they switched over union,
it would be worth millions
of dollars to the union.
It's kind of fascinating stuff because
on one hand you go, well, you know,
unions are important.
If a guy wants to earn a good wage and
you want to make sure that they have some
leverage and buying power
and people should get paid.
But when you see shit like this, like
how could this be right? Like you, you,
the people that worked for those casinos
voted against doing the union thing.
The whole thing is a mess. It's just
like, it's just conti corruption.
And it's gotten to the point where
you're like, they can't back down.
Now they've been spending money trying
to keep the UFC out for so long,
but you just putting your finger on a dike
and there's a, there's a hole in that,
in that,
in that fucking dam and more holes are
going to start popping up and eventually
it's just going to overwhelm you. You're
still spending all these, it'd be insane.
It'd be the same.
They're still spending all this union.
Dude's trying to keep it out.
You know,
it's just so unfortunate were shit
like that happens with two things.
Get entangled, you know, businesses
getting tangled. So this, uh,
the card in UFC in New Jersey's
is a sick fucking card.
It's Dominick Cruz, Hanan Barao, which
is cruise had been out for two years,
man with two different knee surgeries.
One Cadaver ACL graft that blew
out on him. His body rejected it,
and then you had to go back in again,
another nine months of Rehab and then
three months of training so it loses on
ball shots. He loses a
year. Fucking incredible.
So he's finally back fight in
the interim champion and Barao.
And then you've got Joe say
Aldo Fighting Ricardo Lamas.
That's a great fucking fight then. And
then you got me. Or versus Overeem.
There's a lot of good fights to Linacre
versus bag routine off these two little
flyweight murderers. Oh,
those two killers, man.
PAGO teen offers a Samo champion. This
Linacre is a destroyer. The calls him,
they call him hands of stone. You can't do
that, right? It's her to the ranch. Shit,
he can't take shit,
but the kid can't fucking bang man.
He's got ridiculous,
ridiculous power.
Bobby Greens fight enabled to Hilo.
God Damn it.
A lot of good fights,
man. A lot of good fights.
It's going to be crazy too
because getting a back and forth,
apparently you're saying it's
going to be a real issue.
Well those guys are going to be in Jersey.
Yeah,
but you're saying getting back and forth
to crazy times so it's not that bad.
Yeah. But going back and forth
that weekend is going to be nutty.
What is it going to be like that
that weekend? What is it like?
Okay, so you have three titles,
right? The Lincoln tunnel side.
You have the George Washington bridge,
upper and lower,
and you have the Holland tunnel,
right? Plus you have the fairies.
When you do a super bowl,
you have the soup bowl or one location.
So when you go to, uh, let's say they're
going to have it up and uh, the rose bowl,
everything around the rose bowl will
be NFL related for the first two weeks.
The first week is press week.
The last week of the playoffs,
I think it's either a two week situation
to get you to spend more money or it's
a one week. So you go right for the
playoffs, right to the soup bowl.
They come into town the week before
and start practicing and all that shit.
It's not the 18,000 to 20,000
people that come to the super bowl.
It's the hundred thousand people
like a couple of years ago.
Real sport time exposition on how
many hookers fly in for Superbowls.
You'd be fucking blown away. It seems
like a good move. I was a hooker. No,
they had a whole 20 minutes.
I'll have three segments dedicated to the
art of hooking all fucking super bowl,
the HBO,
Hbo at what happened,
what really happens to a city when
they have the soup bowl in your city?
That was the expert say wow.
For starters,
20 million kilos of coke
at shot at 20 million. Oh,
you know they,
people come to the zoo board apart and
so it's not the 18,000 to go to the game.
It's the hundred thousand that come in.
So now this is,
let's pretend you're going to have
the Superbowl in San Francisco.
Everything around that stadium is, it's
going to be related to the super bowl.
They're not doing that
this time that do it.
All the NFL experiences and shit
scattered throughout New York City.
So if you want to see the
NFL experience hall of fame,
you got to go to the
Museum of natural history.
If you want to see the NFL quarterback
challenge, you've got to go downtown.
That's going to create all
that shit that dementia.
There's a lot of things going on.
There's a lot there. Not, as I mentioned,
they're closing the Lincoln tunnel.
One tunnel is only for buses, social,
it'd be one community thing. Now our
boy Alex, we'll get you back and forth.
The other thing I do not like it all is
it's February fucking third and fourth
could snow, could snow and they said it
hasn't snowed in February in 80 years.
You know what that means? It's going to
fucking snow in February. I said in the,
in the, uh, super bowl
in that area in Newark.
It hasn't stone in February and 80 years
old lesson. Is that true? No. Come on. No,
that's not true. What am I? Am I quitting?
Birthday's February 19th and my mother
used to take pictures every year of be
walking into the bar on February
19th at one thing for certain.
There's always snow on the fucking ground.
Let me see what it,
maybe it's that day. Let me see
where they're, what they're saying.
Farmer's Almanac,
a big storm.
The farmer's Almanac is predicting
how dare they, the temperature.
That's hilarious. Temperature reached 71
yesterday where? New York. Oh yeah. Yeah.
It's warm right now. Sure.
That's incredible. Yeah. Yeah.
It was warmer than it is here. Yeah.
It doesn't even make any sense. Yeah.
They said it's unseasonably warm.
Okay. February 2nd in New York,
and this is true February 2nd in Newark.
Hasn't seen serious now in 80
years. Wow. Yeah, so it is true.
Yeah. So it's that day. It's
that specific day. 80 years.
They asked Roger, good, that doesn't mean
shit. Last week, and they asked Roger,
get down, what are you, what are you doing
for the possibilities is no. He said,
you know what? If it snows one to have
ourselves an old fashioned soup bowl,
that would be awesome. I would like that.
No banging up, but you're out of that.
By the time the super
bowl even was the kickoff,
you're in La with your feet
getting a massage because,
well I'm going to watch it.
I'm going to watch it this year.
Try to figure out what, Yay.
I'm not going there. No.
Where else would your feet up?
Eating fucking a meatball sandwich
or something because if not,
I want to find out what the fucking
hype is all about. And I think if I,
if I watched them play in the snow,
I'll really enjoy it.
Well cause this is madness. You
know, I love chaos. If you can get,
if they could have MMA fights in the
snow and you ever seen a wet and wild,
you ever seen the Kandak
cage wet and wild? No.
The king of the cage is
a smaller organization in
Hawaii, right? No, no, no, no,
no. California. They used to have, um,
my friend bud used to own part of it
and uh, they used to have these Emmett,
where the fuck is that? Look at that
last weekend. Where are they flying?
That's crazy.
That is so gangster playing a
game and the snow like that.
I don't give a fuck that is Uber gangster
and to see that there's 18,000 people
in the audience, go to that
audience shot. Look at that.
Look at those mother fuckers.
They're freezing their dicks
off and they're still there.
They're all there. Fuck.
I love that.
I love that they're willing to play
in the snow that it stays so wicked.
How the technology has changed
because now like the size of it,
the sidelines are all heated.
The seats,
a heated throw blankets at either
the heated the gloves, eat it.
It's amazing what I'm fucking cold
getting hit in the cold it. What's that?
American Express commercial
then a $66 a blowjob.
Priceless.
Getting hit in the fucking snow when
it's called prices for competent,
like warm as you got to look in that
camera, man. Yeah, earning his money,
man. Jesus Christ. That's
insane. Yeah. I get that.
East Coast man. It gets rough.
Look at that. I'll tell you what,
when I went deer hunting recently, we went
to Wisconsin for that show, meat eater,
and we sat in a blind,
a deer blind waiting,
and you're sitting in that fucking blind
and it is zero degrees outside and the
wind is whipping and you are fucking cold.
You know why?
Shit, cause you're just
sitting, you're not moving.
It's one thing if you're moving,
like I've been in zero before,
but if you keep moving when
you're in zero, you're okay.
As long as you keep moving,
you generate some body heat.
But when you're just sitting there
waiting for a deer to shop, you can't.
The fucking statute, you can't move. You
just get to sit there. It's fucking rough,
man.
Wisconsin in the winter up
near those fucking lakes.
But God damn, they're deer everywhere.
They're everywhere. You know what's crazy?
We're not used to it. No. Were pussies.
We're soft to east coast at night
one night and it started snowing.
I wasn't crying. I wasn't to the
point, but about you to it. I see.
I didn't say nothing. I was,
you know, I was, I had shit on.
But it's fucking cold. That's a different,
I was in Eugene, Oregon with my bedtime.
Sequoia was nine below zero.
Fucking rare.
Rare cold snap. All right. You know, and
you're like, wow, I forgot about this.
They had some serious snow
while you guys are up there.
This is cool to do for 10 minutes to walk
and get a Starbucks or something. Yeah,
we got to go to Portland again.
Let's do Portland and Portland together.
Let's do it. Let's, okay,
we'll do Portland again.
Then we'll do New Mexico together. Let's
do a Portland, New Mexico this weekend.
Dirty bitches. We're going to be there
this weekend at the Mirage though.
I'm going to have some fun. What are
you doing? New Years? Three years.
I got an early show. We're at the
early show, Jon Lovitz. Ah, okay.
Early show up there and then I'm all for,
I dunno how late I'll be up there,
but it's a Paki shouldn't be weird.
Like,
I forget how fucking crazy the
parking is for new year's everywhere.
If you get to the, if you get to the
Improv and time man, if you want to go up,
you're starting at 10 though.
Yeah,
we're starting to get out of there till
about 10 that's why I didn't know for
sure. Just drive over.
Just try cause it's triple.
He's going to go up and then Tony
Hinchcliffe can go up to be to get out of
there. I don't know. I
never been lived before.
New years so you know we can always ring
in the new year and then you know you
can go up after that too. It
doesn't matter. We'll have some fun.
I'll tell you something.
Joe Rogan.
I haven't been catching up on
sleep or last two weeks have you?
I fucking six weeks in a row on the road.
That's a tough morning radio as well.
That's no grown in radio to what they do.
The death squad people.
That's why people, they give us a little
percentage and they put it all on us.
They put everything on ice.
They figure Twitter.
I see who goes in the week before
and they get three stations.
Don't call us and say,
come in Wednesday for Thursday radio.
I got nothing for us because they don't
even spend a dime on these fucking clubs
when we come in and not more than a dime,
that guts because they put it all on us.
They think we're going to go in there
from the fucking podcast and impact of
play. Well, in a lot
of ways, like you said,
it is like being on TV
shows at the same time.
So it's the same thing and the
word gets out in a better way.
And we do all our promoted.
There's no radio.
How many radio stations you
got left in the worst? Not,
not for radio station that used
not to promote something happy.
The guy in that opie and Anthony Stern,
who else is left?
There's some stuff on the bottom.
Tom, there's a, there's guys, uh,
throughout the country that she could do.
If you guys in Austin,
there's this guy's,
you know,
Dale Dudley Day on Bob Bob's the people
in Fort Lauderdale. Fort Lauderdale. Yep.
Dama,
wherever his buddies,
I had to do like radio for the movie
and I had a call a couple of places.
I was surprised that,
but it's all serious.
You know I had a called BC at all serious.
It's different affiliates.
It wasn't like in the old
days when we'd go to Houston,
you did radio Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday and Friday. The drive through.
What happened to those guys?
Did Dee,
did radio get fucked up by those jack
channels and all those like preprogram
channels? What's the big communism
station? Communism. Clear Channel,
which me just, that's
it. It was communism.
They were firing people for saying
they got mad at, what's his name?
What's the kid that had the chef
Frank Caliendo. They got mad.
Don't even say fuck that kid that
maybe has a fucking his life, man,
I don't know. But years ago something
happened at some clear channel.
He did the personalization.
They thought it was off color.
You know those people in
self fucking easily man.
Well, they're just thinking about
money. They're not. They're not.
It's kind of funny that you're,
you're selling art,
but you're just thinking about money.
Like that's a real hard line to dance.
You're going to make sure
that your product sucks
because your product is never
going to have any edges to it. It's not
going to be anything dangerous about it.
There's not going to mean
anything controversial about it.
Can you imagine if we could have a
radio show where we do like this?
We have a morning radio show and it's
like this completely uncensored and it's
on, you know, drive time, whatever.
Just take this. Why, why you,
why you have a, you know,
some, some other nonsense on,
just take this and if you need
to throw a little beep in there,
throw a little beep.
It's gotta be real people ready for this.
Listen to this society.
People were ready for this.
Well, you know what they're going to be
ready for is having the Internet on their
fucking radio.
The Internet is going to be in your car.
You're just going to download them,
watch them or stream them live.
Joe, how many times can
you get here? Hey Joe.
So what are you thinking this weekend?
Are you going to the race track?
Yes we are. We're going to go.
Nobody wants to hear that no more.
We've gone through that.
1980 is fucking done. Okay,
so nobody wants to hear that shit.
You want to hear that shit?
Maybe that's a suit, but I want to hear
somebody who's telling me to fuck him.
The truth for a lot. I
want to hear somebody who's
telling me their fucking mind,
not what the advertisers are.
Fucking tell them what they could say
and what they can't say that that's the
beauty about fucking podcast. That
is the beauty. That's the beauty.
But I don't give a fuck. You don't
want to sponsor? I don't give a fuck.
We get our word out. This is pirate
radio to the grass roots as grassroots.
As a kick fucking be.
Yeah. This is crazy. Pirate
radios has ever been before.
Even greater radio was getting. This is
good as your fucking pirate radio wishes.
It was the internet. I love doing
this shit with a joint in my mouth.
What did he do? That shit.
I love all that shit. Well,
if you stop and think about it, like
from the moment we started doing this,
all of us, everybody who does it now,
all of us already and Brian and you know,
calen and every, everybody who's
been doing this, we put just,
just doing it to do it. You know? We just
started off doing it for fun. You know,
we started off doing it like as a goof.
So the intention was never as a business,
the intention was to make it as fun
as possible and to make it as, as,
as enjoyable to listen
to as possible to create.
And it becomes sort of like a piece
that you're creating. It doesn't,
it's not like a,
it is like you're having a conversation,
but when you're aware that other
people are listening and you, you know,
you want to make sure that it's,
this is an entertaining,
that there's something to this.
You're, you're, you're like,
you're fashioning a piece,
you know?
And that's a lot of what you're
doing when you creating a podcast.
It's a piece of art. It's a piece. I mean,
it's very pretentious to call it art,
but it's something that you're creating
and that's something you realize along
the way.
That's
all it is,
is there's no difference.
We're going on there and we're given you
what's in the heart and what's in our
head. What sticks out of our
mind. I don't fucking go on you.
I don't go on Yahoo and see what the
hot topic isn't talking about it.
Anybody can do that. Anybody can do that.
I don't want to talk about that shit.
I want to talk about what
pertains to us today. I don't.
I don't go on there and talk about Obama
care. What do I give a fuck a fuck?
You guys bought that Hook.
He's a fucking president.
Why are you buying
insurance from this shit?
I'm not saying the president is shit,
but why are you getting caught up
and I know everybody needs a shirt,
but I'm not going to go in there and
talking about generalizations of sports.
I don't want to do that.
I'm sick of doing that.
How many times have you watched the news?
You have three TVs in your house.
Put them together one day and put
the news on it. Fucking synchronized.
They're synchronized.
Show what they're talking about on four
they're talking about on a five at the
same time.
Then Diane Sawyer comes on and world
news tonight comes on and then there's
another person.
There's an interpretation of world news
tonight with Diane Sawyer on four and
I'm too,
and that covered the same shit that
you're covering to the minute because they
want to get it to you before
anybody else gets it to you. Right?
So we go live now. You know it's the same
shit when you wake up in the morning.
You guys aren't end up in the morning.
You're got to get up at six and
watch TV in the morning and see what,
how bad they get you going in the
morning and the fear they put in you.
Just that all, they talk about
it as teachers rape in a kid.
This happened overnight and this
nothing's positive. Nothing.
By the time you get in your car,
if you have any feeling at all,
you fucking shock.
That's why I get up at
four 45 and I smoked dope.
Then I get on Twitter and I play fucking
music because let's get the fuck.
Let's get our head away from that shit.
Who gives a fuck? You still gotta get up.
You know whether Obama Care's alive
and kicking. When you go to rouse,
there's anybody pop up and pay for
your bills at routes or whatever.
Wherever the fuck are you do
shopping and you read Ben? No.
All right then what the fuck are real
question. When you were at Ralph's,
nobody pops up in the face, but you
know, of course they don't show it. Yeah.
So what the fuck? Wah. I don't
worry about that shit no more.
You worry about your own path and what
you can do and how you can help your
community and your,
some of the people running and you move
forward and if you're not doing that
then what the fuck are you doing?
Well there's a lot of people that
are, are, are not doing that,
but they are involved in the political
part of it. It's like you can't,
I don't think you can do everything.
It becomes a problem if you really want
to concentrate on fixing the economic
system and fix the system. I'm
only here for a short time. You,
you're running up hill,
that's for sure.
But that's a lot of people say that's
a cop out because that's the world that
you live in and this is the, the society
you're supposed to help it enhance it.
You want to solve the world,
you go do it.
All I'm doing is putting you in a good
mood for you to go to fuck out thing and
get out there and kick some fucking ass.
You know,
I'm a fucking this morning and I
was talking to my wife and she goes,
you're a scaffold.
You know the other thing I would go to
the ice house cause I was scared to go
out at night. Why? I don't
know. Because you eat edibles.
That would kill a fucking whore. I
don't know. Sometimes he'd edibles.
Thompson girl came on.
It was telling a story about you giving
him a Chiba chew and about you ate like
three or four of them.
You got,
you had lately like he ate a quarter of
it and you had literally eight times as
much in your system on the
airplane was fuck yeah.
He was telling me the whole story
about it and I was like that.
That's one of the most terrifying.
So just thinking about you
that high on an airplane,
like you're having anxiety attacks.
I was breathing heavy,
I was starting to sweat and just suck
and that's fucking really high man.
What are you getting out of that?
Like what's walking out of that?
I love walking on that. No,
that they would sugar, right?
Either a whole cheat but you,
but it was a 17
milligrams.
It was a Greenwood.
I start my day with a double a one 70
how am I going to do 70 ain't gonna do
nothing. So I gotta pop two
of them and that's one 40
and the third one is two 10
so I'm in range, mid range.
That's how I am saying the amount of
tolerance that the average person,
the the length of time they would have
to indulge in marijuana to hit that kind
of tolerance.
That shit that Jerry [inaudible] was
just talking about about all those local
news. I don't know if you saw a Conan
O'brien. He did a thing last week.
It was brilliant where he took all
these local news channels and showed how
exactly generic they are reporting on
the same story and they edit it together.
If you want to. I have it right here.
Yeah, sure. Makes Sense. It's so funny.
Check this out. Even bigger story
that's sweeping the nation right now.
Who are you really shopping for
this holiday season? It's okay.
You can admit it if you an item or two
or 10 for yourself.
Well, it's okay. You can admit it.
If you have bought an item or two
or maybe 10 for yourself, it's okay.
You can admit it.
You've bought large 10 for yourself.
You can admit it if you borrow an
item or two or 10 for yourself. Okay,
you get admitted. Brought it.
Item worth two or 10 or yourself.
It's okay
to work 10 for yourself. It's
okay. You can admit it. Todd,
if you bought an item or two
or 10 for yourself, okay?
You can admit it or 10 for your songs.
Okay?
You can admit it if you've
got for yourself, okay?
You can admit it for yourself.
It's okay. You can admit it.
One or two or maybe three or four,
maybe even 10 items. You can admit it.
I had a bunch of cars on.
Keep it going.
I'm enjoying the show. This, by the
way, I want to fuck all of these people.
The guys too.
I don't want to or to fall.
It's okay if he's bought an item
or two or maybe 10 for yourself.
Okay? Okay, and can it fun for yourself?
Is it okay? You can admit it. Oh my God,
this is insane. It's still going. Joey.
Joey went to take a leak.
Nobody has a fucking, so
do you guys think this works?
You think that there's like some sort
of a grand script that goes out over the
airwaves. They get these generic
packets from there that, you know,
like NBC and stuff like that.
They could change the wording,
but most days they do not. I do not.
Yeah, they're probably lazy as fuck.
You have no idea what we get coached.
And you have to realize that for
years when you were growing up,
when you were young, you always heard that
cliche. The media controls everything.
Well they fucking, they could
then they'll control everything.
They control what they want you to hear.
Right.
It's control what they want you to hear.
You can't shoot a fucking BB gun now
without the whole country finding 10
fucking seconds.
They will interrupt the fucking orgy.
Now you poured out a kid got
shot in New Orleans by a,
I'm sorry. Oh No, I'm sorry. All right,
look, somebody fall over there. Ah,
what are you doing?
He's showing me gross.
Oh Jamie don't distract conversation.
No, no, no. Ah, and that's
the thing. They, they, they,
so I just don't have
a second conversation.
Those conversation and he think that
we're doing now is because people
eventually just got, I mean, how many
times? I don't mean to put anybody down.
You Watch a Sitcom
lately? No, it's painful.
There are that aren't anything.
They're like fucking everything
on two for Fox and whatever.
They're all the same.
Just rewritten over and over and over
again and there's some nights it's like
going to the main room.
Carlos is on doing dices joke at.
He's in the original room.
Remember that Shit that
night?
Somebody was saying that just one of the
original omen calls is doing decisive
Joe. He just did dices dice. Did
the joke in the original room.
Carlos did the same joke in the
main room one night. This was the,
but I'm not talking.
It's the same thing with ta and that's,
this is why this shit's winning. This is
why more people are turning into this.
First of all,
I know this is this is it mean podcasts.
These podcasts, we do them, we put
them up, they run out of the TV shows,
operate under where they
interrupt things every 15 minutes.
That's it that I watched the walking dead.
You know when you get it on Apple TV,
you can't get it the night it comes
out on TV. So it was out on Sunday.
So I decided to watch it on regular TV
in real time and it was fucking brutal.
They just cab having commercial
after commercial after commercial,
they kept throwing commercials up.
It was fucking crazy.
I was like this is gross.
It's such a terrible way
to watch an hour program.
We have so many different options now
with podcasts and people jumping on going
on like this.
You know when I watch Jay Leno and I may,
I may like the guy from pirates of the
Caribbean. What's his name? Listen,
Jay Leno, if he was smart, he would
host a show on cars. That's a no, no.
I'm just saying what's the
guy that goes on in there?
What's the guy who was Johnny Depp? We
all like Johnny Depp. I love Johnny Depp.
Ain't gonna go on. They'll
actually promoting the movie.
I aint promoting nothing.
I'm here talking to you.
So every,
so tell us about what happened that
time you were shooting on the set.
I did my own stunts.
Get the fuck out of my face.
You'll fucking half a fag
fucking Scott's I right.
You know it's the same shit.
So eventually some people said fuck it,
we can't do this no more. These
things to me are interesting in shit.
I listen to podcasts. Yes. The different
assortment of educational podcasts.
I try me to the history one
is fucking great by the way,
cause I'm a history reading. Uh,
and they're very interesting.
And even when you're doing the podcasts,
he listens to one that's educational.
It's not calming. You're like,
wow, I like how they're doing that.
As you heard radio lab, you ever heard
of Radiolab? Radiolab is really good.
It's um, it's interesting too
because they add in sound effects.
They like tell a story and
they edit it really well.
They'll do an interview and
they'll explain things as
the interview is going on.
Like they intersect a narrator explaining
things as they're going on with a cool
sound effects and shit.
It's like really well produced.
So like they have a premise like one of
the premises was why are these athletes
from this one particular era in Africa,
why are they such good runners?
Like what is it about these guys
that make them good runners?
And then during the whole show they'd
speak to experts to talk about it and then
they ultimately speak to a guy who was
born and raised in that tribe and he
explains what it is.
It's a combination of factors,
but one of them being is
brutal circumcision thing
that these guys have to go
through unbelievably brutal rites of
passage to become a man when they're
circumcised you with a sharp stick,
they make you crawl naked through thorns.
Like it's like really hardcore
shit. Like what they make
these people do, they make the,
they make them run like on a regular
basis while their dick is like twisted up.
Like they have their four skin
tied up in a bow and they're,
they're running naked. When they get
outside the, uh, the hot, they also have,
they have to run,
they can't walk anywhere,
like incredible rites of passage to become
a man that is so brutal that they get
through this and they have this insane
tolerance for pain and they have this
genetic predisposition to be good runners,
like the way their bodies shaped
and built. Fascinating stuff.
So listening to it on this podcast
made me appreciate like that style of
podcasting. It's an is, it's a
different style obviously then we do,
but I like that, you know, everybody's
got to be creative now with this thing.
People were sick and tired
of it, you know? Listen,
I've said for years I've said that.
And I normally, the soap people,
I don't know who fucking stays up and
watches those talk shows later than
flipping through the channels.
I don't fucking know why this
Dalon half the fucking time.
I don't fucking know who watches that
shit on a fucking and now you got sad.
And I live with now they've got to put
stars on every week to make it work.
Every fucking week.
They've got to put somebody famous.
Now I get home on Saturday from
doing something and it's Miley Cyrus,
Justin Timberlake, and Paul Rudd. Got
It. No, last week was the other guy.
What the fuck did you,
what happened to the regular fucking
sign that live cast that nobody watches
that shit. So you have to have
those fucking people on there now.
But that's amazing.
Who Watches late night talk show?
Who the fuck tolerates that shit?
You do chemo but looks at that fucking
Conan clip was great. I'll Kona Kona.
It's not at nine o'clock.
What time is here here?
It's eight o'clock nine o'clock and Pete
home comes on at 10 I watched Kodak.
I'm talking about 11 fucking
third Pete Holmes show.
I've never watched the beginning of a
couple of minutes there as he doing the
same standard thing like
monologue in the beginning.
And then I think he turned to his
is like a podcast show also. Eric,
I haven't watched the whole thing. My
friend watched it. He's on um, after Kona.
Is that what it is? Yes.
That's all I have to call it.
And then there's Craig Ferguson still
does pretty no fucking watch that shit
that with the fucking morning.
I don't watch the other guy,
Jay Leno kill me fucking day.
Every once in a while.
I still got a hot out from my main
man, Dave Letterman. That's my dog.
That's all I watch him.
If he's got somebody cool.
I know he's got a goof on him or
something. He's still an interesting guy.
He's very interesting. I've, oh,
I loved him since 80 fucking too.
I've been watching David.
You know where you get to really
see an interesting side of him.
He's in a comedians getting in cars,
getting coffee.
You know that web series,
the Jerry Seinfeld did.
Have you seen that one
with David Letterman? Yeah.
It's really interesting because he has
a Volvo that he drives around and it's
crazy. Souped up Volvo and a, someone
famous called them up like, who was it?
Who was it that wanted to know if he
wanted one of those? Volvo's some,
some other crazy fucker, some
other crazy famous fucker. Forget,
I forget who it was, but someone, uh,
said, hey, I'm a, I'm buying these souped
up Volvo, so you want one? He's like,
fuck it.
Count me in.
So he got this Volvo with a six speed
and like a fucking ridiculous high
horsepower engine. Looks like
a crazy, like a regular wagon.
You know that you would drive around in,
but it's, it's brutal. Click on that shit.
You see can see what it is. That's
a big time. Bold the car too. Yeah.
Oh, that's an ad, right? Is
that an ad? That was, they just,
they get show those fucking 15 second ads.
I liked the skip ad option or like,
are they doing that skip back in five
seconds? Yeah. You got to get me quick.
You've got to get me quick.
Yeah.
This is a Volvo.
He's got a Volvo wagon.
This is the 1995 Volvo nine
60 station wagon. Oh my God.
Really?
It is in region bread.
It has a black leather interior,
premium sound system and a sunroof, but
it was built with the high performance
racing engine by none other than Paul
Newman. It's a lady horsepower Ford v
eight with a supercharger and a Mustang,
five speed gearbox.
It looks like the kind of car that you
would take to a place like this and do
things like this,
but it's actually a car where
you can do things like this.
He's doing a burnout. Oh, how rude.
Anyway, that's an interesting web series.
So He's another one like Jerry Seinfeld.
Like I like him in that more than
I even like him doing stand up.
Like he's really good at that cause he
loves fucking cars that guys addicted to
car. Should we Seinfeld,
he's a huge Porsche owner.
Like he owns like some insane amount of
Porsche's. I mean I think he's got like,
like,
like huge garages that he owns that are
dedicated to these cars is actually a at
an airport in senate. Yeah, but not just
here. Also on the east coast as well.
He's got a separate one set up over there
and he has a full time mechanic that
takes care of all of this stuff.
This is like,
they're just constantly
working on his car.
Like he has like rare cars are
worth like 1 million bucks,
like rare first edition,
you know,
1973 nine 11 at rs cars are
super hard to get ahold of.
He's a car nut.
So like Jay Leno too,
like one at Jay Leno's best things
that he does is Jay Leno's garage.
It's a thing that he does online and it's,
it's,
I like it better than the tonight show
because the fucking guy loves cars.
I mean, he's in love with
everything and not just fast cars.
He's got a bunch of old stupid cars.
I don't like these crazy like 1910 fucking
shit boxes that he's got rebuilt and
he, he drives around in them.
Is this Jerry Seinfeld's
place? Yeah, just layered.
Yeah. He's got like all kinds
of cars. Mostly Porsches,
but obviously you could see there
he's got a Chevy Camaro. Ss. Vw Bug.
Yeah. He's got a fuck load
of cars, man. He loves him.
I mean, Hey, you know,
people are in a weird shit.
Some guys are in the steroids
or the guys are in a guns.
Jerry Seinfeld's in a car. Fuck
it. Get that Cadillac though.
Joey, do it. Do it. Do it. Do it.
Let's let your wife drive the Subaru.
No,
she has the fuck Cadillac
or that fucking gangster.
He has the one that I want
to say a silver one. Two.
You need one that looks
like it was fake shit.
That wasn't the call of the year last
year. Everybody got what does die?
Hondai oh the um, the one that looks
like a Mercedes. Yeah, she's got that.
Those are supposed to be great. Somebody
told me those cars are fucking great.
This guy who knows cars told me look,
the difference between that and then
Alexis, it's a barely evident. He's like,
yeah, the Lexus is a little bit sharper.
It's a little bit like higher tolerances.
It's a little bit better
designed, a little bit more
high end, but not that much.
He's like that fucking car.
The one that looks like a Mercedes and
Hyundai Manx he goes like that is like
the bargain fucking car the year.
That's a fucking gun to great car.
I've done 80 just, I did 110 coming back
from San Diego one night. Like nothing.
Nothing. Nothing. Yeah.
I have a friend of mine is
Korean and he was just like,
he was a doctor and he was always talking
about like Korean work ethic and like,
he's like, you don't know man. He goes,
when these guys make a car, it's like, oh,
cause it was when Hyundai was first
coming out. I was like in the 1980s yeah.
And he was like, listen man, these
cars are going to be good. Yeah.
A $4,000 car that went ballistic.
They were great.
I knew salesmen selling Hyundai's making
$20,000 a month on $400 commissions.
That's how many fucking holidays that
we're selling amongst all those little
four doors.
It's called,
I forget the Hyundai
still are super cheap.
They were relying on,
they went away for a while and they
came back with all new thing. Yeah.
And you know it's like Mitsubishi,
like I've always said there's a
Mitsubishi part and every fucking car.
Mitsubishi has shit every fucking
car. A lot of, what's the well set?
What did Mitsubishi built? They built
the plane that drove people crazy.
A world did this.
Mitsubishi built the mic.
That's why a lot of old time people won't
buy fucking heavy cars with Mitsubishi.
Chrysler.
Chrysler had Mitsubishi Products and there
are a lot of people and these Sundays
are expensive down this [inaudible] e Q.
U u s equity is $60,000
zero they ain't fuck.
Yeah Dude. But when you look at
it, it's like $120,000 Mercedes.
It's a dope fucking car man.
And you know the Hyundai and lunch room,
you know it's a ball.
It's a ballsy move to,
if you've got some money and you buy a
Hyundai, like you don't want to pitch.
This is good enough.
This is all I need
is the opposite of the Cadillac move.
It's the ANTIFA loss.
Where was it looking at it right now.
Which car? Which one is the echo?
E? Q. U. U. S. E. Q. U. U. S.
Yeah. $61,000 man. That's not cheap.
That's what it starts at the hale.
Yeah, but it's a rock solid car in
comparison to the like the high end Lexus,
like what's the high end Lexis?
Let's say hi and Lexus,
Lexus ls four.
He's 4,600 it starts off at 71 so it's
like not that much of a savings and a
Mercedes Benz s five five zero is yeah,
they're comparing them right there.
The ultimate,
so the equities ultimate is 68,000
and the Lexus ls four six 60 starts at
71,000.
That Alexis is a motherfucker dude.
Those Japanese, those designers and
engineers that they have that uh,
worked for Toyota and then went into
Lexis and made the high end Lexis.
I had a Lexus truck. I still
miss that truck. Really? Yeah.
At least it at least did. And I was
a, I brought it with me to Colorado.
I missed that fucking truck. It was
perfect. It was one of those big ones.
I think it's called the LX. The
SUV got, damn that thing was good.
It was just rock solid the way it handled
in like snowy weather and the use,
the way it drove, even though
it was a big car, like all the,
all these systems that were designed to
stabilize at around corners and stuff
and you know, is adjustable
suspension. Fascinating stuff man.
And they're the ls, which is their big
flagship. That's the one that's their, uh,
they're big, uh, you
know, they're big sedan.
That thing is the first
car to parks itself.
It parallel parks itself and
they like it finds the spots.
Have you ever seen that? Yeah. Ford has
that. Awesome. They just it at all. Yeah.
Yeah.
I would trust the,
what has the braking system
to Alexis, right? Well,
they have a lot of braking systems.
There's a lot of different cards you're
talking about with cruise control.
I don't know which curves. It's like
that smart cruise control. Yeah. Yeah.
But there are also,
uh,
there's things that recognize even
when you're not on cruise control,
they apply the brakes. If you're getting
too close to cars. This car right here.
I was like that lane departure warning
where it tells you if you'd like to go
over in a lane. Yeah, that's fascinating.
I have that on my SUV and it also,
uh,
we'll slow down if there's
a car in front of you.
It's like a laser guided cruise control.
So say you get on the highway, you say,
okay, I'd like to go 70 miles an hour.
Well, if there's a bunch of traffic,
it slows you down to like whatever.
The traffic's going like 40.
And you don't even have to put your foot
on the brake. It slows you down, man.
You have to put your foot on the
break of everything gets dead stopped.
But then when the traffic picks up,
it'll pick up.
So it'll go back from 40 back to
60, back to 70. That's amazing.
They came up with a new Mercedes
that drives itself, man.
They were reporting about it
in the Frankfurt auto show.
The newest auto show is this guy,
Chris Harris. I always follow, uh, uh,
he's a really funny automotive
journalists. But, uh, he was, uh,
there at the auto show and they were
talking about this new car that literally
you're gonna be able to sit in and it's
going to follow the curve of the road.
It's going to break. It's gonna
accelerate, decelerate it,
do like virtually everything
that a person does. So they're,
they're super close to that kind of Google
technology from more than one source.
I know the Google car
has been real successful.
They have a car that drives itself and
hasn't gotten into any fucking accidents
and a certain point in time it's
going to be like, why would,
why should we let people
drive he fucking dummies.
You crash into each other if you,
if nobody drives ever,
you just getting your thing
and you press the button,
there's never going to be a crash again.
Isn't that better? That seems, I mean,
I know that it's nice
to be able to drive it.
I like driving and I
know you like driving,
but wouldn't it be better if we knew that
no one that you love would ever die in
an automobile accident again? And
that's how it begins. Joey Diaz.
That's how they take away your freedom
and that's how skynet goes live.
And it's all coming
through Google coincidence.
They just bought the
fucking robot company, Joey.
They bought that Boston dynamics. They're
making fucking robot frogs and shit.
Robot Cheetahs. What's next? Joey Diaz?
Friday night, the Mirage Friday
night. Ari should fear Brian Cowen,
Joey Diaz. Um, anything
else coming on? Brian?
I know you got to get a gang
shit going on in Texas, right?
Yeah. January 9th, Houston, January
10th, Austin, January 11th. Dallas.
Where are you? Uh, where are you going to,
what are the places? Uh, so people know.
Yeah, it's in a, in uh, Houston. We're
going to be at fit scare, Fitzgerald's,
and we're doing a podcast before the
show and then we're having a show me and
Tony Hinchcliffe and then in Austin,
the January 10th,
Tiffany Haddish is joining us and we're
going to be at the spider house of
ballroom. And then, uh,
July or I mean January 11th,
we'll be at the curtain club in Dallas,
Texas again with Tiffany Haddish,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
good Google lead Moodley
and this a Friday night.
Of course the Mirage.
But then the 31st Christmas Eve,
I'm at the Melrose Improv
with Tony Hinchcliffe and
the lovely and talented Sam
Tripoli should be an awesome fucking time.
January 24th in Chicago. Oh,
Jesus is going to be cold.
Me and the motherfucker, Ari Shaffir.
We're going to have a good time.
January 9th, 2011 buffalo, New York.
January 23rd to 25th.
I'm in fucking
Hawaii. Let's just go to Hawaii. Oh,
why is a fucking great place to go
no matter what you're going to do.
What did you do? Jay Dunkin just got
back. He was in Maui at a fucking retreat.
That's how he's balling.
How he's living. Yeah.
He went to some crazy
spiritual retreat and um,
talked about it on his podcast and met
a bunch of people from the podcast.
They were there, but he said it wasn't
even weird. It said it was weird at first,
but everybody was like so tuned in to
what the retreat was actually really all
about. That it all turned out to be
like a really positive experience.
Could you do that? Could know.
I could never tell it. Shut up.
Don't even put that fucking out there.
Bunch of freak show up.
Do you write your name on my ass? I'm
going to get it tattooed. Settle down.
Look, I stay after every show and
I meet people after every show.
I take pictures with everybody until
they're tired of taking pictures.
I try to be as accessible as possible.
I talk to people as much as possible,
but I think those type of scenarios where
you're just constantly around people,
like you were saying, like on a boat
or something with most of the people,
like literally 90% of the people or
more that you run into it, it'd be fine.
But there's that 10% that don't
know when to leave you alone.
Don't give me any space occasionally,
but that's what they'll ask.
That's what I say to them occasionally.
Let's not, can we not talk about me?
Joey, a jam band in his friend made a,
a song with uh, Joe, uh,
with you and your blue cheese and
all that stuff and another song.
I think they've finished. Are you finished
it, you guys, you should all drown.
We said ended the show with that.
Let's do it. Um, that's it folks.
Thanks to audible.com go to
audible.com forward slash Joe,
get yourself a free audio book and
30 free days of audible service.
We love them.
They're excellent.
Can't say enough good things about
audible.com they are in fact the shit.
They also sponsor hardcore history,
which is one of my favorite podcasts ever.
So audible.com forward slash joke.
Get yourself a free audio book
and on at.com that's o n n I t.
Use the code name. Rogan. Save 10% off
any and all supplements. All right,
you fuckers. We'll see you
soon. [inaudible] Christmas.
[inaudible] I love you.
Big kisses.
Let's get our freak on.
Bless the shit.
That's the shit.
[inaudible]
motherfucker.
All
that
family guy watching spike was the shit
family grab watching Spongebob Spongebob
Family Guy.
I'm watching.
That's the shit mother fucker.
Was it up
under the seat?
Sandra
[inaudible]
Greek freak freak.